are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
[Music]
all right episode number 165 today with
adam sauce
vinnie osana and jeddah diabeela we got
a lot of things to cover we got an
announcement today i got to tell you
guys what this backpack is shout out to
scott rodriguez american cuban
entrepreneur
some may call it a satchel but it's not
a sound
but i got to tell you what's special
about this and he sent it to me it's a
great great story i'll tell you guys
here at the end of it and he's he's part
of the membership by the way he's part
of the pbd podcast membership which is
great but we got a lot of stories we got
a lot of stories to get into interest
rates went up three quarters of a point
which we'll talk about what that really
means 30-year mortgage rates are
officially 6.28
hopefully if you did a refinance was
last year amazon's going to start
sending drones vinnie's concerned about
that we'll talk about that
biden's telling oil companies and letter
well above normal refinery profit
margins are not acceptable elon musk is
expected to reiterate desire to own
twitter in meeting tuesday bitcoin is
crashing a ton uh coinbase lays off 18
percent of people elon musk says he
would publicly vote for ron desantis and
when ron was asked about it he said he
will always gladly support the vote of
an african american and people hated it
anyways we're going to talk about we
have a lot of things to cover and we got
a special announcement at the end to
make with vinnie as well so how you guys
doing how are you feeling [ __ ]
fantastic yeah that's the new yorkers
over here yeah those tough guys you guys
look like you guys are about to sell
stock oh you guys are dressed nice and
financial you guys are closing deals
we're about to go flat somebody
some people what's the problem we're
making jokes and they're making money
exactly that's the problem like what's
up
we got to bring it we got to bring it to
the middle because you know i was saying
when i was off the camera these rich
people are something really pissed off
they're cuz so i think they're they're
they're losing being you know touch with
reality right
they're like oh we get it inflation we
got it we're bothering yeah we got to
work jedidiah first week three episodes
how you feeling oh we had a blast yeah
tyler knows he knows what's up we had an
absolute blast honestly like we rolled
out we're doing like a lot of hot topics
we're gonna be pulling guests but it's
it's so much fun
first time ever of just having a mic
just being able to go
it's amazing everyone in the crew that
was my question for you because
everything i've ever seen you do is it
paneled oh yeah now you're just so hello
mike here's my mother thoughts
how does it feel i just you know what i
feel like so unfiltered and just like i
i feel like a dog who's been take to
take that muzzle off and they're just
like
a fifteen thousand dollar dog by any
chance or listen we did we did a fun
story with that tyler knows we did a fun
story about the mat you guys have to go
and check out some of the clips on the
show about the man who became a dog 15k
would you spend 15 000 to fulfill a
fantasy listen we all have things we
like to be a dog or to buy it
he bought a dog costume he gets in the
costume and he acts out scenes like he's
a dog he heals he is like an adult film
guy or what's what's
there is there a twist to this story or
no i i think there's some type of fetish
going on there
i've met a lot of weird fetishes this is
a very yeah unique one i've not heard
this one before so listen everyone if
you see me show up and i'm in a cat
costume one day don't be surprised
where it got started the inspiration
came here from this man shut it up i'm
gonna join you in a cat cop step back
we're gonna be turning around just
licking this is what should happen adam
you and i show up vinnie you can do it
too we all come in cat costumes to the
pbd podcast we don't tell pat
oh my i would love first of all that
would be great
you i don't like surprises that surprise
i will that's great so i just want you
to know
i'm prepared for it but by the way my
dad
so he just found out about your show
three days ago okay so he didn't know
last week he wasn't subscribed to her
channel so he subscribed next thing you
know he's watching it back to back to
back he says i am in love with this lady
i'm so in love with her approach was she
saying she's such a badass so my next
time you see my dad he's going to be a
little bit star struck because he's in
love with you so love it shout out to
gabriel
i gotta give a shout out to you we're
speaking of dogs cats dressing up by the
way i'm totally 100 in on that but you
saved someone's life yesterday oh jimbo
straight up holy moly talk about being a
hero not talking not being a hero i'm
working out yesterday and it's me and e
shout out to you the trainer and i'm
looking outside i'm saying he's trying
to jump to the next door neighbor's
backyard oh my god and he jumps i'm like
this guy's not going to make it because
my dad put a new fence so he jumps i'm
like he must have fallen so we run
outside we're like no this guy's in the
inner coastal fell in the inner coastal
anyways i have to jump in go get him
i got all these seashells bleeding all
over the place i'm in the intercoastal
thinking if this blood you know you're
thinking jaws sharks are showing up
alligators are showing up but uh no we
were safe we brought them out and
something tells me jimbo will never go
in that corner everybody
never again and the only thing that
bothers me about dogs oh the only thing
you did all that bad you
bleeding your clothes your jewelry could
have fell off your your friend had to
help you dogs never just take a moment
and go
thanks they just
he just goes and eats over here let me
tell you
this guy jimbo has been the greatest
therapist i've hired in my life
hasn't charged me a penny i would come
home when you're building a company it's
a lot of pressure come home it's
midnight he's sitting on the couch right
next to me and i'm just like frustrated
and he's just listening doesn't say
nothing and then i'll go to sleep so
jimbo shout out to you for the greatest
therapist in the world
you've had him change my life and cooch
for 13 years or 10 years wow
they're they're twins brothers
yeah
it's amazing may of 2009
uh marlene
del toro guyton
said these two dogs i said let me have
them for one night that was and that one
night turned into 13 years finished
she's a great salesperson and he saved
you ever have a cat oh yeah cats are a
little bit different
you turn on you gotta realize i love
chickens i had cats my whole life my
parents have cats but and i love cats
because they're independent they're like
me they're like come at me when i'm
ready when i'm not ready go away i'm
kind of like that i get it we understand
each other but cats can turn on you dogs
are much more appreciative that's a good
point but if you're gonna get cats get
two oh yeah just get a buy one get one
that's how it works it's easier than
that i'm just letting you know that's
how i got my question but you could go
on vacation for how long and leave them
food how long can the cats do that oh i
do my thing every weekend i i would just
leave them okay three days
my whole thing with dogs yeah and this
is what happens now we're going a whole
animal segment now
is
you don't have no idea like in miami
group i'm on a boat we're on a yacht
we're having fun yeah and i grew up like
i gotta go i gotta go walk my dogs we're
in a freaking yacht yeah in the middle
of the ocean and sarah over here needs
to leave the whole party go walk her dog
come on sarah i never have to do that
with a kid it's always a stair that's
what you gotta do can we make a shirt
for adam to say i'm a cat guy can we
make it like that he's amazing
we need to put some kind of because he
loves telling everybody he's so proud of
it it's like i love my cats i actually
don't like general cats like yeah yeah
streets you don't go on pedophiles
okay but by the way congrats on shaving
uh saving jimbo's life not all heroes
wear capes pat some wear satchels
you're getting some love apparently
officially you are the david david
hasselhoff of miami
i'm not going to take that no although i
will tell you living in germany in the
80s and 90s late 80s
david hasselhoff was god
he was god he had a song the bayway i
mean he was just all over the place
can you name
three names of the actors on baywatch
i'll give you if you can name pamela
four give me four names pamela anderson
okay david hasselhoff yeah
from charles in charge yes yeah yeah i
gotta leave i gotta go ladies and
gentlemen she is so hot you're revealing
your age by the way adam i know 38. i
think you're very young somehow i'm old
still younger than me there you go
anyway pat let's bring this down
can we get into the story since we got
all these things out of our system is it
okay if we go into some stories about
them i want to know how they're going to
chop up that short clip or what they're
going to call it so so let's talk about
the fed hikes that took place this week
okay and
for some people they're like well what's
the big deal with this we're going to
talk about that here in a minute so fair
hikes benchmark interest rates by three
quarters of a point the biggest increase
since 1994 this is a cnbc story on
wednesday they launched its biggest
broadside yet against inflation raising
benchmark interest rates three quarters
of a percentage point in a move that
equates to the most aggressive high
since 1994 the rate said setting federal
open market committee took to levels to
of its benchmark
to a range of 1.5 to 1.75 the fed's
benchmark rate will end up at 3.4
that compares with an upward revision of
1.5 percent point to march estimate the
committee then sees the rate rising to
3.8 in 2023
a full percentage point higher than what
it was expected to be in march officials
also significantly cut their outlook of
2020 economic growth now anticipating
just a 1.7 gain in gdp down from a 2.8
percent so adam you see this to the
average person who sees this
okay
0.75
how does that affect me but to somebody
that's been in financial industry for a
while what does this really mean to the
average person so
what i talk about like for instance
let's just talk about what the fed is
right we're talking about the fed rate
of rate hikes so at the helm of the fed
is jerome powell chairman of the fed
he's been there since the trump
administration
uh now he's in there biden kept him and
then we got janet yellen who is
um secretary of the treasury and then
you got biden in there so those are sort
of the three-headed monsters basically
controlling the monetary supply right
now uh what's the purpose of the fed so
obviously you know they're they're they
control the money supply we've seen how
much money they've printed over the past
three years right how many five trillion
bucks that you know just boom right
there so we can touch on that you you
had a debate with the father the
godfather of quantitative easing you're
not a fan of that i assume right you
don't want to you don't want it i'm not
i'm not a fan of
bailing out the people at the top and
complainers 100 that's not what i'm a
fan of the people at the top are big
boys
and the people at the bottom need to be
inspired by people in the middle who
actually do the day-to-day work to make
money pay the bills support their
husband their wives their kids pay their
taxes send their kids to school raise
their families become good citizens
america's ran by the people in the
middle that are quiet that don't get a
lot of recognition those are heroes and
sometimes the guys at the top and the
guys at the bottom complain way too much
the doer doers nothing you know what i
mean by the guys at the top
you know what i mean by the guys at the
top i don't mean to i don't mean the
doers no no no
there is the the complainers
there is those in the middle that are
just doing the day-to-day job they don't
need the recognition they just want to
go out there and do their part okay tell
me what the guidelines are i'll go find
a job i'll go get better i'll go pay my
bills i'll go be a good citizen
there's the creators and the initiators
who are at the third level who are the
future they're the ones that make things
happen they're the ones that make things
better they're the ones that innovate
make technology better make products
better make systems better make our
lives better that's third level and then
there's a people at the top who used to
do that and now they haven't for 20
years
and they just keep doing buy back buy
back buyback and they found a way to
maintain their wealth at the top that
they're no longer in the creation and in
in the initiation mode
and they're taking money from taxpayers
to say bail me out those guys shouldn't
be bailed out those guys ought to go out
of business and let the market decide
who's the next future to future the
country that's my problem with the guys
at the top and the complainers at the
bottom makes sense yeah so the interest
rates go ahead you were saying well so
basically the purpose of the fed is uh
you know stabilize unemployment
stabilize inflation stabilize um
economic growth or obviously it's not
stabilized hopefully there's you know
gdp increases i think they're they're
now predicting it's going from two
they're predicting three percent down to
like 1.8 whatever but the fed has a role
okay so at the on the macro perspective
this is what the fed's doing that's what
drill pal is doing how does that affect
everyday people okay so
it's gonna affect everyday people in one
of two ways you're either gonna wanna
have lower prices or higher
interest rates okay so
what i so in being a personal finance
expert i talk about the seas of debt the
seas of debt what are the seas of debt
credit cards
car loans and what i call cribs
mortgages so if like some people you
know what you're doing you'll go get a
mortgage if you don't know what you're
doing and just kind of figuring out it's
like i gotta get a [ __ ] so borrowers
people who have debt
people on the lower rung of society this
is not a good look for you what's
happening right now that's great if
you're a saver like me who saved money
and is debt-free
this is a very opportune time to
capitalize right now so for instance i'm
looking at this and i'm like i feel for
the american people i feel like there's
been a lot of fake money that's been
printed and has been earned over the
last few years you know an nft i just
bought it for 300 grand i'm gonna make
him now your nft is worth 30 grand good
luck if that okay crypto's been cut in
half we all know the game stuff it's not
cut in half more than half oh ethereum
is down 78 okay so even but bitcoin's
been cut in half or even more they were
60 grand 60 percent you're right you're
absolutely right so i'm trying to give
crypto people to benefit the doubt less
than half more than half but
if you've actually do what i talk about
have a budget maintain cash flow you
understand your income and your expenses
you stay out of debt you work you earn
you actually put in the work you don't
just sit home and collect unemployment
you've saved you've invest you have your
financial house in order this is a
major major opportunity to capitalize so
i'm looking this and i'm thinking okay
all right i haven't bought bitcoin in
since 2018 i got in when it was very low
and i haven't bought i've been looking
at the prices i've been seeing these
[ __ ] people who don't do anything and
they're just kind of crypto rich a lot
of the gen z and i'm thinking
now i'm gonna go probably buy like 510
bitcoin boom all right at 20 grand a pop
all right cool so if you've got your
house in order this is a major major
buying opportunity
but if not if you're like most americans
78 of americans are living paycheck to
paycheck they're struggling you know
this is a rough time for you but you've
had two three years to kind of get your
[ __ ] together and if you haven't
hey it's on you what are they talking
about the k-shaped economy the rich have
gotten the richer the poor getting poor
to your point
bad policies have what consequences have
consequences so they've they've printed
five trillion dollars if you've taken
this time to say all right you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna double down on what i do
i'm gonna get better at what i do i'm
gonna save my money i'm not just gonna
go spend it and just like
ball out on random crypto nfts and i'm
actually gonna just figure my stuff out
and work and not like take the easy way
everyone wants to get rich quick these
days me i've been saying this for years
for years people are like what do you
mean i want to get rich slow how does
this jedi die vinnie for you you're
you're a mother okay
hartley married you know how do you feel
with the what does the interest rate
hike do to you like how do you and
jeremy process it when you're talking
about it at night
i mean truly i'm listening with open
ears right now because this is that when
you intro this segment and you you read
all that stuff it sounded like a foreign
language to me it took me seriously i'm
not immersed in this stuff like my first
question was when i heard this i was
like i'm curious what your response
would be if somebody came on because
people view the fed as the enemy they're
like this this is just it's a it's like
a foreign entity to a lot of people my
question was like what if there was no
fed what would happen people are curious
about that if the fed didn't exist what
would happen to the market what would
happen to what would happen not right
away what would happen in five years say
the fed
it's gone what happens
the
the market would decide and and currency
would need to be backed up by something
so you would need to have the currency
backed up by
a gold or a you know something that is
would that ultimately be a good thing
though or a bad thing it would it would
be a good thing it would be a good thing
but if you ask the people that are in it
they would say it's in too deep for that
to go away that's not going away today
because we're so into deep there's so
many people that said end the fed ron
paul yeah right you know all the stuff
no no no question about it of course
they're getting but here's the part you
got to realize so to the average person
when rates go up prices go down very
simple when rates go down prices go up
so a million dollar loan
at six percent the payment is going to
be a different matter of fact pull up
the calculator mortgage calculator best
way to show it right now to see exactly
what this works out we've talked about
this before but it's very simple just
type in mortgage calculator go to
yeah right there put it put a million
dollars okay and go to six percent
okay what's the payment almost 59.96 now
go to instagram now so so how many
people can afford a six thousand dollar
payment right now not me not a lot of
people so go to five hundred thousand
dollars six percent
okay
five thousand it's what roughly three
thousand dollars that's five million
that's three thousand dollars okay so
now take the six percent so remember
that number three thousand that's at six
percent that's at six percent take that
six and make that three
it's gonna be twenty-one yeah exactly
seven hundred dollar savings so now
somebody would have said i can't afford
a three thousand dollar payment yeah
increase that three percent to six
hundred thousand dollar loan make seven
hundred thousand dollar loan seven
hundred k
so watch that
you could have bought a seven hundred
thousand dollar house at three percent
because payments 29.51
but now you can only buy five hundred
thousand dollar house at six percent
because it's the same payment so if you
bought your house at 700 grand
unfortunately the market is saying it's
worth roughly now 500 000
and people are not going to believe that
right now because they're going to sit
around but 6 to 12 months the market's
going to say that why
i consult a lot of guys that run real
estate companies and mortgage companies
here's what they'll tell you
the inventory of homes for sale just
blew up
just blew up the other day i talked to
one of the top guys in la that sells
exotics i said what car was impossible
to get last year that's everywhere today
he said a unique lamborghini if you
wanted to buy this a year ago at any
time the market only had two or three of
them he says there's 59 of them for sale
right now what does that tell you let me
say that one more time a lambo that you
could own there was only two or three of
them for sale last year because p the
bitcoin people everybody was buying them
mortgage people real estate just buying
them buying a buying them no but today
there's 59 so what does it mean so it
means you went to a club
and you're at an army base this army
base has a hundred
soldiers
98 men two women
what happened there the attention those
two are getting which is what happens in
a military base that's the only two
options you got and 98 guys are trying
to get with these two girls
go to another military base it's a
hundred soldiers now there's 58 girls to
42 men that's the base you want to be at
yeah that's what i'm saying
but enroll in the military by the way if
you're look if you're the guy you want
to be at the at the unit with 58 girls
but if you're the girl you want to be at
which unit the one two you want to be at
the barracks but only two girls so if
you're a seller
last year benefited you if you're a
buyer today's the buyer's market so
what's going to become critical today's
patience and here's what's going to
happen to the seller hey sellers if
you're listening let me give you guys
some feedback take you to do whatever
you want to do with this
you know how you're stuck on the fact
that you think your house is worth 4
million dollars and you're trying to get
a million dollars today don't make that
mistake
you're going to lower that price from a
million to 900 to 800 then you're going
to sell it at 700 a year and a half from
now here's my suggestion to you let
everybody else have that same house in
the market that the comps are shown at a
million you put 910.
you put 910 no one's looking at all the
other houses you're gonna get five six
seven different offers you'll end up
selling it at 9 30 9 40. in your mind
you're thinking you lost 60. believe me
you didn't lose 60.
you made 140. okay because a year from
now you're going to sell that thing for
800 dollars don't this is not a time to
be greedy if you're a seller this is a
time to be greedy if you're a buyer
greed hasn't changed it's just changed
if you're the buyer versus the seller
that's all interest rates matter and by
the way goldman sachs just said that
they're going to raise the interest rate
18 more times 18. for how long well how
long of a period this is the next two
years so fantastic great so by the way
the goldman sachs gets [ __ ] wrong so i'm
not telling you they're the messiah but
they're goldman sachs so they said
they're predicting this rate's going to
change 18 increase 18 more times and by
the way even with all the interest rate
hikes that they've done the last six
months okay all the interest rate hikes
that they've done last six months tyler
has that slowed down inflation the last
six months
so so so watch what i just said
let me say this to you
even
because interest rates you you increase
so inflation goes down right inflation
goes up if interest rates are down so
you try to control it it's okay guys
let's keep increasing interest rates
inflation stays low right here's how
scary the economy is right now
even though they keep increasing the
interest rates hoping inflation goes
down inflation is still going up
meaning this is not flipping do you
understand what i'm saying to you like
so so three quarters because you have to
assume that if they just raised it by
three quarters because last week
everybody on twitter
everybody on twitter was messaging
saying
uh inflation went to 8.6 percent 40-year
high 40-year high 40-year high and jimmy
carter officially is a more popular
president than joe biden and everybody
from the left don lemon the other day is
interviewing what's her name his new uh
replacement before jen sackey is saying
hey you can't tell me it's like well why
could you ask a question like that yeah
how could you ask a question like that
so now the administration's talking to
the fed and saying hey you gotta
increase the rates maybe three quarters
of a point not just a quarter because i
didn't do [ __ ] because we got to have
because what they're hoping for is in
july for them to say inflation dropped
from 8.6 3.5
they're hoping that happens i will tell
you it should happen
but if it doesn't happen
this shit's a lot uglier than people
think it is great let me uh strengthen
your argument let me let me give you a
layup right go forward so you're
familiar with the fear greed index you
ever heard about that yes so every
month they sort of calculate the
sentiment of the country so when it
comes to money you can either be greedy
or fearful warren buffett has basically
said be greedy when people are fearful
or be fearful when people are greedy
over the last few years during
covid everyone's been greedy they're
printing money crypto's going crazy the
stock marks going crazy everyone looks
like a freaking genius right now oh i
bought an nft for 100 grand it's worth a
million but everyone's being greedy now
if you look at the fear greed index
right now i haven't actually seen it in
a few months the last time i looked at
it it was closer to greed we are now in
a time of
extreme
fear so what does this mean
obviously like i said before pat
if you if like right i'm because i've
saved that money and i've just been very
calculated and i haven't gone and ball
out and bought a lamborghini over the
last few years i could have but i'm like
you know what save save save save save
save when i've had the opportunity to
buy a sick pad i'm like you know what
let me just rent when i've had an
opportunity to buy a dope watch i'm like
let me buy a bitcoin what have you now
if you've got your house in order now's
a great time to be greedy so were you
following everybody's fear so you were
fear so technically you were feared
not me i but my my fear was for what
could happen here gotcha like
again if you've got like so i don't have
pvd money but i'm doing all right okay
yeah like if i get another zero or so
i'll be on pbd's level but i've got some
zeros but
it all depends on your age and like
where you're at in life but
so let me ask you a question just you
know
average person listening to this right
now
let's say they're either living paycheck
to paycheck or they're living a little
better than paycheck to people they hear
all this stuff and all they zero in on
is what can i do sure all they see is
their prices are going up they can't
they can't even get in the car to drive
to the grocery store and put gas in
their car without it being a problem
everything is becoming a problem at the
most basic levels for these people so
they're saying to themselves they feel
very powerless in situations like this
they don't have a lot of other options
maybe they didn't have an opportunity to
save a bunch of money so they're sitting
on limited options limited choices right
now
so
can they do anything and how much of who
wins the next election
has to do with this in other words let's
say biden is out somebody else is in how
much is affected when it comes to these
deep financial topics that people
honestly don't oftentimes have time to
dig into major leagues so what does it
look like let's say it's not biden well
let's say it's it's desantis let's say
it's trump paint a different picture
well let me explain to what happened so
last year
uh not last year 2015 2016 when it was
between hillary and uh trump
and wall street experts came out
and they said we're getting behind
hillary hillary's winning okay
when that announcement was made the
market tanked for a while okay i don't
know if you guys remember this the
market tank so i'm in the business where
i saw the market tank because everybody
was bracing for impact with what with
hillary okay
but then the day trump won
under obama's administration the last 60
days of obama being president the next
day the market blew up
if you just go look at go november 4th
whatever the day is november 3rd
november 14th of 2016. and matter of
fact just pull up november
2016 stock market that's all i want you
to pull up 2016 stock market november
okay
uh uh go to it go uh uh no go back
go back and and see if you can get the
whole month
see if you can get the whole month
anyways you look for this you'll see
the day okay is that it
okay look at that look at that look at
that right there wow look look when the
elections are
drops concerned boom it goes up the next
couple months because it's the trump
effect
people knew that guy knows how to drive
the economy okay so so so the day
biden was announced that he is look what
happened to the market same thing so you
can the market knows what's going to
happen the market knows what's going to
take place
uh the moment he got in and he said he's
going to do what he did with oil right
off the bat in january february when he
made that decision and it was a big
pivotal moment to the election where
trump said okay hey oil people texas
listen to what he just said he warned
everybody you're going to pay the price
for this it's very simple
when i was coming up in my early 20s and
all i'm thinking about is i got to make
money to retire my dad from working at
that 99 cent store in inglewood that was
the only thing on my mind i'm like i got
to retire my sister's going to go on a
nice honeymoon and i gotta pay off my 49
thousand dollars of debt those were my
three main goals that i had right i
didn't pay attention to politics i
didn't give a [ __ ] about who's doing
what i didn't even understand policies
capital i didn't know none of this stuff
okay i didn't want to deal with it
because politics my parents got a
divorce i don't want to deal with any of
that stuff
then all of a sudden i made money
and i said you better pay attention to
this stuff
because you can't just go the rest of
your life like you know sometimes people
like in the world of business they'll
say things like i'm the vision i had a
guy that i went to in long beach i was
consulting with this guy says i'm the
visionary i don't deal with the minutia
i pulled him aside i said i said you can
never say something like that if you're
the ceo the founder of this company
because you have to know the minutia or
else you don't know how to manage and
drive the minutiae so if somebody wants
to be wealthy but you don't want to pay
attention to the economy and the market
you're contradicting yourself if you
want to create wealth you have to shift
the way you look at the economy and the
market because policies have a massive
effect i hope if if the last you know
five six years from 2015 to 10 to now i
hope if the last six seven years did
anything it got people to pay attention
to policies more closely because it
directly impacts your kids and who do
you love more than your kids your
political party no hopefully it's your
kids if you love your kids more than
your political party start paying
attention to what's going on with these
policies because their future is relying
on how you vote very simple that's what
i was just getting at too because these
people that feel powerless i'm always
like there's power in your vote you can
do something and what i hate is people
sitting at home reading these stories
and feeling like it's out of my hands i
can't do anything no matter what i do i
don't have the finances to really make a
big difference but if you know that you
go to the voting booth and that has a
big effect and that has a ripple effect
out and that has the potential to create
better policies for the economy at large
people feel powerful i hate when people
feel proud i'm going to give you guys a
totally different perspective here and i
do agree with pat but that's on a macro
perspective like
i don't give a [ __ ] how you vote if
you're not working and saving and
getting out of debt i don't give a [ __ ]
what policies you agree with because
your house is drowning so let me address
your question specifically i don't care
if you like i've made money under biden
i've made money under trump but i've
made money under obama
don't care okay but what i'll tell you
is this if like because i do appreciate
what he's saying exactly the policies
printing money that is a thing like that
from a macro perspective 100
but also you need to look in the mirror
and you need to say all right cool
uh there's a big difference between
wants and needs
and what happens is when your
wants kind of become your needs and you
and you and you and you develop what's
called lifestyle creep i was making 50.
now i'm making 70. so
time for me to get a nicer apartment i
was making a hundred now i'm making 150.
i feel time for me
no i tell people all the time okay you
got a 20 raise save that money so it's
on you like so i also say this there's a
big difference between poor and broke if
you're poor
and you're a single mother with two kids
with two jobs
there's nothing you can do that's funny
okay there's nothing you can do get
smarter read more like like you're not
gonna make more money but most people
are not poor most people are broke they
make 50 grand a year and they spend
fifty five but so does that ask you a
question patrick so but and here's my
thing and going off with you what you
said jedi the
everybody says it's happening and under
joe biden my thing is why why are they
doing it and i saw something yesterday
where they're like they've been trying
to get rid of the middle class all these
policies all these things and it's
actually working i understand what
you're saying but those people that are
trying and hustling and doing their
thing that those people in the middle
it's going to be either you're rich as
hell or you're poor and that's and
that's where it's going and nobody and
it drives me crazy because a lot of
these like polls and these stats and
percentages they're like 50 of people
you know i think that it's going bad so
does that mean 50 of the world of
americans are like yeah what
this is good looks not good i don't
necessarily
agree like at the end of the day you
need to look in the mirror and you need
to take accountability for yourself okay
like that
i
i had to take two years of my life
sacrifice
make you know how it is when you start
off in financial sales you need to eat
[ __ ] for a couple years but i went in i
was a [ __ ] party boy in south beach i
was having a great time i'm at the time
of my life making zero money and i said
you all right i can continue down this
path of having a great time and just
crashing on friends couches or i could
eat [ __ ] for a couple years buckle down
learn a trade have a specific undeniable
inflation proof skill set and for the
next 15 years i'm gonna make money
that's true but the jobs need to exist
so when you're talking about that you
know single mom and she's sitting at
home with her kid and you were saying
you know she doesn't have a lot of
options there's not a lot she can do
well there is a lot she can do she can
get a second job potentially a lot of
people dig themselves out of that hole
but those opportunities need to exist so
if you're living in an economy where
people are firing instead of hiring
because they can't afford it where
you're living in an economy where
minimum wage and policies like that come
into effect and they prevent people from
having opportunities that's yeah but
what's up what's that lady's skill set
i'm sorry you if you don't have a skill
you're replaceable if you're making
fifteen dollars though it doesn't matter
let's say i don't know what her skill
set is but but let's say let's say it's
minimal she can still get a second job
she can still do something she can still
do something there are people who climb
from the very bottom of the bottom up
but those opportunities have to exist in
the society they live in because if you
go out and you want to get a second job
and there are no second jobs because no
one's hiring because the economic
climate sucks you're in trouble that's
when you're really interested i hear you
about saving no no but i'm not even
saying saving it's you know what we're
in america here
go to any other place in the world and
give that little spiel they'll be like
i'm just trying to survive we're still
in america here we're still the greatest
superpower in the world still to this
day you know knock on wood hopefully
china doesn't surpass us anytime soon it
might happen but still
like look where you are in the world god
bless america and god bless the fact
that you could choose and to become
whatever you want in this life and you
could always i'm not saying that you are
but you can always play the victim role
the economy sucks and joe biden and gasp
but at some point
that's just reality
people are not hiring and you're looking
and you're grinding and you're hustling
i mean i know people right now trying to
find work that are having a really hard
time their skills what they do over the
last three years though what they do
some of them got fired because they
wouldn't get a jab and now they're stuck
i mean there's a lot of lockdowns look
what they did i know people who start
work their whole life to start
businesses in a place like new york city
build that business up feeling great
lock down they can't handle being closed
for three months they pick up they have
to go to a new city they have kids to
support people are in circumstances now
that we haven't seen in a really long
time all i'm saying is that
if you if you have someone at the very
top of the heap that's not that's not
creating policies that trickle
opportunity down and people ha people
feel like they have limited options
that's going to decrease their ability
to climb out of a hole no question no
matter how motivated they are or not
these policies do have an effect on
individuals that macro hits the micro if
you're a small business i 1000 agree
with you but most people aren't small
business owners how many small
businesses are in america adam i will
tell you both of you guys are right
here's what's crazy but
both of you are right you're right and
she's right okay
this is a documentary that came out in
2008.
uh it was with david walker the former
comptroller general of u.s i i have i
brought him out to an event in 2011.
uh he he's like the the cfo of america
is who he was for like 10 or 12 years
okay david walker there's a scene in it
which is powerful
a lady who's a single mother asks warren
buffett hey uh uh what do i do i'm this
i'm in this situation i'm going through
this financially i'm going through
whatever what do i do to change my life
right now because i don't know how to
come out of this he sits there and says
look it's not going to be pretty it's
going to be ugly but here's what i will
tell you go increase your market value
that's what you need by the way this is
08. so if you remember oh wait by the
way if you haven't seen this documentary
go see it because it pretty much shows
what we're about to go through it breaks
it down
exactly what we're about to go through
this documentary breaks on i o usa with
david walker first time i was introduced
to this guy was by a couple named dinan
dino fliss who are very successful
financial folks but uh so you're right
regardless it's your responsibility to
go out make to make money and do
something with it but she's right
everything rises and falls on leadership
leaders policies affect people's lives
so it's kind of like saying well no
matter how bad of a father you had you
can still go out there and make it
you're right but hey people with better
fathers they have a really big impact on
kids lives you're right do you get what
i'm saying so yeah everyone everyone has
a difficult starting point there is
truth in both and we have to keep
pushing both messages do something with
your life can we have better policies
that's right i think both ways we need
to help well that and to go back to your
point i said pat gave you the macro
perspective policies fed interest rates
listen there's things that matter
and there's things that you can control
you need to focus on where those two
things intersect things that matter and
things that you can control breaking
news you're not going to control infra
interest rates you're not going to do it
no matter what you do you're but you can
control all right cool i made five grand
this month how much i gonna spend them
on rent how much i'm gonna do in a car
payment by the way it's summer
everyone's planning on going on vacation
right by the way everyone just got their
tax refund you made you made you got 3
000 back from tax refund this is what i
talked about wants versus needs what are
you gonna do with that three grand
you're gonna go on vacation you're gonna
mykonos yeah you're going to st parks
you're going you're going to niagara or
you're just going to you know what let
me pay off my debt this is what i'm
talking about you have choices you have
options we're still in america baby
i want to validate one thing you just
said because it's very important that we
we get the facts right you said i went
from a party boy
to to business
adam this is pure because we like to
tell the truth here we go
it's a different story i appreciate it
all right let's continue with this by
the way when you save that money and you
uh yeah thank you thank you
thank you change things change your
mortgage
all right 6.28 cnbc said this which i
want to just add this at the end of it
higher home prices and rates have
crushed home affordability for instance
on a 400 000 home with a 20
down payment
the monthly mortgage payment you ready
the monthly mortgage payment went from
13.99 in the start of january which is
only five months ago to
1976.
guys
this is america let me say that one more
time on a 400 000 property with a 20
down payment which is what 80 grand
on a 320 loan your payment went from
13.99
five months ago tyler to 1976 not in a
year not in two years in five months and
you're not buying a two million dollar
home you buy a full hundred thousand
dollar house with a 20 20 down payment
that's 80 percent of america by the way
and patrick you remember we talked about
this when uh when brian when callum was
here so what when people are saying in a
year 18 months it's all gonna change
what what what does it take for
something that keeps going up it keeps
going higher i know people talk about a
bubble and all that stuff i i don't even
know what the hell that means but when
people were like
not bothered you guys are talking i felt
like my head was going to pop off
but uh
because i'm that person that's you know
hustling and you know and doing their
thing and like you guys talked about the
policies it's like the writing's on the
wall trump i'm not sticking up for the
guy but he said everything that was
going to happen i just saw um instagram
clip before i came in here everything
that he said was going to happen you
know the second amendment you know
prices gas this everything that this guy
said is happening and what trips me out
the most is i have a lot of you know
liberal friends and my cousins are
hardcore liberals but like the people
left it's like nothing it's all good for
them nothing and that's why y'all talk
all the [ __ ] you want about the left and
these hardcore uh liberals they stay the
course and they go down with the [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ]
but you know what the left reminds me of
remember in titanic when the the glacier
every they're [ __ ] gonna die and the
violin and the people are doing that
that's the left the left is like we
don't give a [ __ ] gas yeah that formula
we're [ __ ] staying on the ball but
that's a problem they're going to give a
[ __ ] in in
midterms
we don't want to say we told you but the
writing is on the wall like
well let me tell you they did i'll tell
you why they did care because a lot of
them a lot of those liberals got up and
they left new york city in los angeles
they live here now yeah so they cared
enough when it impacted their own pocket
that doesn't mean that's going to change
how they vote because there's a loyalty
to the cause there's a loyalty even if
the cause is burying you the cause could
have the shovel with the dirt and just
putting it on top you're buried alive
and you're buried alive but the cause
has to win but it'll change where they
go because they're like well i can't pay
those that's why pat talks about uh the
ten percent that run america are in the
middle swing voters oh yeah look the
reality is there's two you know what
team you're voting for for the most part
you already know who you're gonna vote
for in 2024. you don't even know who's
running
but you know who you're voting oh yeah
it could be the it could be jimbo it
could be his dog i'm voting for the dog
i'm dead that's what i'm saying
so cat
president two cats two cats but the
point is there's gonna there's ten
percent that's saying i don't know let's
see who knows i'm in the midwest i'm in
toledo ohio i'm in youngstown ohio i'm
in detroit michigan i'm in des moines
iowa these people who are who run the
country it's not the liberal in
california and it's not the yeah you
don't think what i don't even know if
it's ten i don't even know if there's
that many people undecided at this point
i really don't i think the underlying
numbers are gonna think it is i think
it's like slim to none honestly i really
do because i think i really there's
people who are looking at this and
they're like
i i can't go along with this maybe they
voted for maybe they were republicans
who voted for they were republicans who
just many might know something you mean
all the rights there's many people
what what has played out with the mass
on the
if whoever runs for the democratic wins
i'm going to call cheating right now
that's it i'm going to call it this
or was it 10 1 000 mules or did you guys
see that the documentary by two thousand
two thousand mules
that said that they saw it they were
shocked that well maybe you've got to
see it to have feedback on it we'll
we'll we'll see it and we'll have
feedback on it but you know to to go
back to what you were talking about with
the with the voting side the 10 percent
uh and what happens these next six
months if this thing gets worse and
worse and worse
listen when when the left turns on the
left
it's over the writing's on the when
obama and michelle are out campaigning
right now to save their party you know
something's going on
when obama and michelle are out that's
when stuff is really going up because
they're like no no no no we're not
biting no no no no we're not this
there's rumors right now that susan rice
is running america and nobody even knows
about it and susan rice is right
actually american
rights
through obama obama's running america
through susan rice
uh but do you have a problem with that
by the way i i am not a no as far as
being an american do you have a problem
with that i well listen first of all
this is going to sound very strange i
would much rather have an obama over
biden okay that's not strange at all
i would much rather have an obama over
biden and a 000 and if a person in the
middle of the right can't say that you
are you are part of the problem because
at least obama could come out at a time
like this and give a message
and calm the nerves and we could move
out right biden can't even do that at
least obama could come out and give a
message where people are not crazy
overreacting he was poised to give a
message like that but biden went on
jimmy kimmel the other day
i was watching i'm like jimmy cut him
off
cut him off this is bad for america for
him to be shown that way finally jimmy's
like i think it's uh we got to go to
break and we'll come back he's like yeah
it's probably a good idea do you don't
say stuff like that the president says
yeah that's probably a good idea you're
the freaking president they talk about
being presidential the guy that's
supposed to be presidential is not being
presidential so what the hell is
presidential obama presidential this guy
not presidential okay you going hey
trump's not presidential a lot more than
a guy we got today right now if you talk
about being presidential anyways so look
folks if you're liking this format and
you miss it give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel quick shout out
to a couple of our insider
uh guys uh who are the top level insider
members kevin northcutt a a eddie gomez
michael peterson m1 shout out to you
guys uh for the membership that you have
on a monthly basis supporting us uh we
do what we do uh because of you you come
out and you listen to our uh content or
argument and that's a way of showing
support to us and we salute you so shout
out to those folks and by the way if if
you would like this is just a quick test
that we're doing i gotta i'm working on
a project that we may or may not do if
you would like if you'd be interested to
say pat i'd love it if you guys did a
once a month podcast that's live that's
a live audience with a hundred people in
the room that maybe i can sit front row
and give some opinions and the format is
three hours i can be a part of that with
guests you meet the guests take pictures
with some of the guests if that's an
interest of yours tell us through giving
giving us a thumbs up and subscribing
and maybe in the comment section saying
pat we'd like to see that taking place
if it does we may introduce something
like that in the future so let's
transition away from finance because
obviously our experts here on the left
love talking fine let's transition from
finance and let's go to what elon musk
said about ron desantis let's talk about
that so page four so elon musk says he
would likely
vote for
ron desantis for president 2024 this is
an insider story by the way
musk was asked wednesday on twitter who
he was leaning towards voting as a
president and he responded the sentence
he made the comment after he was asked
if he would vote for republican for uh
for president and he said tbd to be
determined or or to be decided uh he
added that he supported the democratic
candidate andrew yang in 2020 election
but believes desantis has a better
chance of winning in the upcoming
election musk said last month that he
would vote republican in an upcoming
election despite having voted for
democrats in the past years
and described himself as a moderate
neither republican nor democrat but
wednesday's tweet are his most explicit
political statement yet so jedediah when
you heard this what was your reaction
and were you surprised i was not
surprised okay at all uh my reaction was
great i think ron desantis is the i
don't know if he wants the job i don't
know if he wants to run he's the guy to
run he's 100 the guy to run
um
it's unsurprising to me you know you
were talking before about you know biden
and obama
biden has you know multiple problems not
being coherent a lot of the times is one
of them i don't even think that's funny
i think it's a serious matter i think
people around him in his circle are
showing him an immense amount of
disrespect by letting him go out there
because oftentimes he doesn't make any
sense something's going on there i'm not
a doctor i can't say what it is
something's not right
um the other thing is is that the left
has gotten too extreme they have gone
off the cliff so when you talk about
andrew yang when you talk about an obama
those were people that what was extreme
back then was conversations about
redistribution of wealth remember that
moment the joe the plumber moment we
were all like wow i can't believe that
was extreme
mandating that somebody should have to
have health insurance that was extreme
that was the whole debate about
obamacare can you force a 21 year old
who doesn't get sick a lot who doesn't
want to pay for health insurance to have
health insurance those were the
extremist points of view now look where
we're at it's gone completely mad
between the masking between the
lockdowns between all of these policies
mad absolutely mad so i think that the
people that were once democrats and were
once saying wait a minute i thought
democrats were supposed to stand for
freedom i thought democrats were
supposed to stand up to big corporations
i thought democrats would be the ones
leading the fight against big pharma i
thought they'd be the ones front and
center on that stuff they're not doing
their job according to a lot of those
people in the center now who lean left
those people are also not deaf dumb and
blind they own businesses they're seeing
what's happening they have kids they're
sending their kids to school they know
that what's being preached out there all
this woke ideology these are not
republican talking points and they know
that because their kids come home and
they see what their kids are learning
and their kids talk to them so this
stuff that's very extreme legitimately
extreme has gotten very real for these
people like a musk he's a very
successful businessman he is not a dumb
guy he knows that what's happening right
now is not good for the country so i
think you're going to see a lot of
people in his category i don't mean
financially in his category but i mean
people like that who are like i'm not a
committed republican but this is messed
up universally stepping out and they're
going to go the way of the desantis's
they're going to be able to vote in
these small local elections don't forget
your local elections those are the
powerful ones you change your community
at the local level first that's where
the big impact is then it shifts out
it's going to make a big difference so
i'm not surprised i'm very pleased to
hear it and i think you're going to hear
i think there are a lot of elon musk's
out there not finally not financially
although we all wish that was the case
hey i'll be an elon musk but um you know
when it comes to mindset 100 that is in
more places than we realized vinnie what
do you think i think uh he's
i think uh
he's right number one in that uh
uh but i think i don't think my mic is
on there's no it's something okay sorry
um i think dimasu i think desantis is
trump-ish if you think about it just not
as extreme he's always cracking jokes
he's always he's always funny he's
always like in the mix
remember we had his press who was here
pat that we interviewed there's no way
that he's running is he one hundred
percent
yeah christina uh pusha yeah he's not
well she doesn't want to say they've
never said it she never said it yeah
yeah if they do go if they go at it like
would that they'd have to debate it's
gonna be
stories are coming out that he may run
by the way this is what desantis said
when he saw the tweet yeah i welcome
support from african americans
funny like that's come on that's yeah
trump would trump wouldn't be that
clever but that is come on to be clear a
lot of people don't know that elon musk
was born in south africa
some people like what is he talking
about there's there's some wittiness to
desantis on that one well here's what
i'll say as as much as jedediah doesn't
know about financial stuff she's very
well informed when it comes to political
stuff so respect to you i think the
reason why elon musk i'll put myself in
that category not the billions but as
far as like mindset goes where it's he's
come out he's never voted for republican
i think he said that he's never voted
for a republican i'm also in that camp
okay but we're at a point now where
we talked about on the on the last
podcast we're looking for some freaking
common sense at this point we're looking
for someone you know joe biden was
supposed to be the uber driver to drive
us home because there's a drunk driver
at the wheel that was the whole premise
but it seems that the dementia is
affecting his driving so at this point
essentially america i think you know i'm
using elon musk
as a bellwether a canary in the coal
mine for america they're basically
saying
we don't need the orange bad guy anymore
we don't need the old creepy sleepy joe
guy can we just get a normal
[ __ ] who makes sense that
america will get behind and what i wish
for america we talked about as
synergistic i hope and i pray that we
have a president that has 60
approval rating when's the last time we
had an american president who had 60
percent approval rating meaning it's not
just 50 50 or 49 52 like when's the last
time that we've had 60
approval rating i think george w bush
had it when he came into office that
plummeted but i think what america needs
now is someone who just unifies and says
this guy's got common sense yeah i've
been a democrat my whole life but i'm
going to vote for this guy yeah i'm a
typically republican and i'm i'm a trump
guy but i don't like what he's done for
the country and i i'll vote for a
descent like
desantis
i don't know if people want specifically
ron desantis or who he embodies i don't
know if that makes sense i'll tell you
what they want from this it's not about
desantis i do think he's funny and i do
think he knows when to get out of his
own way which is an art form in politics
because you can go too far and you turn
people off trump did that a few times
and i think he lost a lot of people
doing that when yeah a few no but a few
noted times where people were like okay
i'm out yeah um but like i have a
specific moment where i was like right
and many the david duke moment i was
like you don't know who david you can't
denounce the kick i was like i'm not i
think everyone has that everyone has
that moment and many people can point to
this moment with trump yeah
desantis is going to be harder and by
the way
you bring up a very good point here
once you make that decision mentally i'm
out it's like if you're dating someone
and there's some there's something they
do
you're like yeah yeah she snores or yeah
yeah he's disgusting he smells you're
out yeah there's no matter what they do
i don't know but it's very hard to go
back to that i don't know about that i
think we're a very forgiving country
we we have such high expectation from
everybody that's on the big screen but
we're a forgiving country look how many
athletes with their past mistakes that
they made and how quickly we forgave and
we move on we are about redemption i
would love to see biden redeem himself
i'd love to see it what are you talking
about i got two and a half more years to
i'd love to see him read him whether
he's a one term or two term i want to
see him redeem himself i'd love to see
uh trump redeem himself i'd love to see
any of these guys redeem themselves
if you if you go to a point that you're
out there's a difference between dating
uh where there's zero commitment versus
a guy that's now your president you want
to see that person redeem themselves if
you're running a company
almost every single one of your
employees
or the leader at the top is going to
make a mistake
there's there's not anybody that's not
going to screw up
so some screw-ups are small
some are mid-sized some are big and
you're going to have some tough
conversations with people and what do
you do do you automatically just jump to
conclusion and say i'm done with this
person no you give people chances to
redeem because then that person says
this guy is forgiven he's given me
chances but then there's a limit to
chances so maybe one two three four five
six okay then you gotta move on and say
this guy's just he's got a bad attitude
as long as for me if your attitude is
solid if you're working on yourself if
you're a team guy if your ego is
manageable if you're not defaming people
behind closed doors you're acting good
on the outside and then we're gonna make
your work at the company and we'll
improve together right so for me this
whole concept of also expecting
perfection from all our presidents that
is so far behind me with clinton i'm
over to expect these guys to walk on
water that is not my standard my
standard is you screwed up you're going
to you're the president and we're going
to judge you this job sucks however a
thousand years from now they're not
going to write about the average person
in history books but they're going to
write about you so if you're part of the
history books and you're going to get
that kind of accolades you're going to
be on cover of all the magazines you're
going to write a book that's going to
sell millions of copies you're going to
put a tweet that millions of people are
going to follow there comes pressure so
can you please make some better choices
because we're relying on you to improve
yourself so i come from that thought
don't get me wrong both of these guys
have said a lot of crazy things
but this is america we believe in
redemption i like what you're saying i
love the message i love it
i have to go with adam on this one i
can't believe i'm about i'm about to
ruin my career by saying i'm just
agreeing with adam just so you know but
the thing about it is i think i would
love for a lot of people to have your
attitude i would love that because
that means that when you say i want joe
biden to come out of this and i want him
to do better you're rooting for your
country you're rooting it's beyond
politics for you it's beyond joe biden
it's it's not personal it's not personal
it's like i want the country to do well
i want him to come out of whatever's
going on and i want him to do better
that's that's a wonderful way to look at
it however i don't think that's the way
a lot of people look at it i think
people make a decision
people who can't stand trump
they will hate trump forever they
wouldn't no matter what the earth could
be caving in and jesus could come down
and say trump is the guy who's gonna
pull us back out and there would be
people who said i got to sing what a
perfect transition
into the next article can you please
bring this up
what a perfect transition into the
gallup poll that just came up pull up
the gallup poll that you have pull up
the gallup poll that we just i gave it
to yesterday so here we go watch this
record high 50 of americans rate u.s
moral values as poor okay so this kind
of
goes to where you were going and where i
was going watch this
50 say moral values is poor 37 say only
fair 78 think moral values in the us are
getting
worse consideration of others cited as
the top problem with state moral values
we've been talking about this on the
podcast for the longest time
we no longer talk about morals and
values one of the whether you're a
christian or a catholic or a jehovah or
seventh day or lds whatever it is the
basic foundation of judaism the basic
foundation of any of these religions is
what
forgiveness
is like kindness
don't judge you know steal
all of this stuff is the basic
foundation of these morals and values
right
if we don't teach these basic morals and
values none of us will forgive none of
us will talk about redemption none of us
will believe in that i think this is the
problem america has today when 9 11
happened nobody cared about your skin
color we all became americans when kovit
happens everybody hated the orange man
and everybody became enemies because it
was your political party before your
country this validates every point that
we talked about on this on this uh what
do you call it on this podcast here
schools
i can't tell you how many parents i'm
talking about where
we had one of our friends that we were
just talking on public school what
happened to their kid they're like i
can't send my kid back to this public
school i just i'm not comfortable why do
you know what's the number one reason
why they can't send their kids back to
their public school morals and value do
you know why people are doing
homeschooling morals and values do you
know why kids are people are sending
their kids to private schools morals and
values do you know why church attendance
on some churches is that a
record-breaking high right now where
people coming back because people are
starting to realize if they're not going
to give it to me at my school i'm going
to put it on morals and values do you
know why the football coach that is
known as raising great men that strong
values and principles do you know why
some parents are getting out of his way
or her way to challenge the kids to
become better human beings because he or
she is setting the tone with the kids of
injecting the right morals and values do
you know why certain companies with ceos
and executives are starting to recruit
talent that are coming to them saying
listen i'm here because of morals and
values
this topic right here no one is talking
about because this is boring
nothing about this is exciting nothing
about this gets people to say oh yeah
let's go this is going to go viral let's
talk about this on cnn or fog let's talk
about this nobody wants to hear this
because this is a boring but necessary
topic
all of us
like
we don't like it but all of us
internally when we look back and we
think about a leader or a coach
that pissed us off the most or a
relative
it was typically a person that expected
more from us
and we were like man i can never get to
that level but you know that's the
person you remember you remember the
worst and you remember the person that
pissed you off because they expected
more from you it was kind of like i can
never reach this guy's level totally get
it but you know what at 42 you're
sitting there saying hey listen
you know what i'm missing claire kind of
love you man appreciate you thank you i
am who i am because you challenge you go
back to that right anyways what do you
think about the [ __ ] of that well one of
the things that i think broke this for a
lot of us was technology um if you i
think social media
and hiding behind phones and not having
eye contact and not having real
interpersonal relationships i think it
broke people hide behind if you look at
social media people say things on
twitter they would never say to you they
would never say to your face so i think
the rise of all this technology and and
putting distance between people and lack
of community one of the reasons i think
that 911 and covet were different
because after covid everybody was
isolated they were all separated you
became the enemy you over there oh you
i'm in my house and i'm staying home and
you're not staying home you're the enemy
oh i got a vaccine and you didn't get a
vaccine you're the end if people where
that didn't happen was in places like
florida where people were out and about
and they were talking to each other and
you realized you had a shared humanity
you talked to somebody and you said oh
that's not my enemy that's just somebody
that made a different life decision than
i did
so that that's the difference i think
technology is number one and i think big
media is the other problem
big media i always say division is a
business model in big media and i think
they thrive they thrive off of screaming
and yelling oh let's put two people on a
screen split screen and have them yell
at each other but we're not gonna solve
anything we're just gonna we're just
gonna present this view that they can't
stand each other and that trickles out
so i think that that that's the part
about how we don't see each other as
people anymore which is why when when we
sat here with nikki freedom we had a
discussion people were like where is
this well it's not happening because
people don't do this anymore because
cable news doesn't thrive on it and
social media doesn't thrive on it so you
have to find and make those spaces
that's number one i think the morals
are a little bit that's a when you when
you dig deep into schools and what's
going on that's going to become a
different conversation about woke
ideology and all that but the very
fabric of like i'm a human you're a
human we can disagree i respect you you
respect me let's hash it out that is
increasingly vanishing and you have to
think are our kids who only know a world
where all these phones are out and
social media are they going to grow up
able to have these conversations or are
they going to have lost that completely
skip that step because they don't have a
basis of comparison we had how many
years in the world before i didn't have
a cell phone until i was 19. i had a
normal functional childhood these kids
in an ipad and a cell phone we did on
the show this week virtual this and
virtual that and metaverse screw the
metaverse you your kid wants to play
send them outside send them in the
universe really
honestly get them out of here
put that on a shirt by the way i'm gonna
i'm gonna do something right now that uh
jack carlo be careful he's coming
here's what i'm gonna do to jedidiah
right now
slow clap because everything you just
said i literally wrote down as like a
talking point that i wanted to discuss i
swear to god social media all your notes
okay community i'm like
bingo bingo you're copying my notes
why can't we get back to when we're
copying each other's notes in person
again like we all did in high school we
all cheated but
um you know there was a famous quote by
jfk asking out what your country can do
for you ask what you can do for your
country we've lost that that sentiment
of community and country and you know
the other side is the enemy you know
i'll never forget you talked about
social media i'll never forget when i
started my show sales talks money i went
around i was interviewing all types of
people
and one of the most lasting
conversations i had was out in l.a at
venice beach kind of right where we were
a couple weeks ago
and uh it was like this kind of like
cholo gangster type of guy mexican guy
and i'm like so what's going on with in
america with the money is like the
problem is everyone's so selfish and a
selfie
is all about yourself
i was like oh
damn and i was like oh like a selfie is
you're more concerned with yourself that
i was like okay go ahead buddy it was
like yeah selfies are ruining the
country values and principles exactly
let me tell you guys so i get this this
backpack here that's sent to me that you
know fedex box comes in jen's like babe
there's a gift waiting for you i open up
the fedex box i don't know what this is
i'm like okay why is
at first i'm worried because it's dirty
it's all i'm like what who would send me
a gift like this you know so my kids are
sitting i start reading this letter
and i'm reading this letter by a man
named scott rodriguez i talk about this
at the beginning of the podcast first
generation american cuban he's 35 years
old at the san fernando valley santa
clara valley which very familiar with
that area county country valencia he
talks about his parents who started a
business with one truck in 1986 and they
build it
in 2004 to 25 million dollar a year
business they sell it and they retire
and he's going to school while he's in
high school and you know he's got this
one teacher that he's working with mr
whitmire i believe is the name yeah carl
whitmeier
freshman year at heart high school in
new hall california in 2000
and carl came out of retirement to be a
teacher's aide in my studies skills
class okay so he's always there but he
never talks about military stories
because he used to be in the military he
used to be in the navy right for 16
years right and so he says he was a
gunner he's this and basically every
time i would go up to him to ask him
stories at 13 years old he was i was
just a 13 year old boy
he said he would never tell me any of
these stories anyways fast forward
to the point where he's no longer coming
to school because he's got lung cancer
and he's asking everybody where is mr
whitmire i got emotional reading this i
had generated because it was an
emotional story anyways finally he finds
out that mr whitmer is in a hospital on
his death bed
he says i come back to school january 6
2002 which is 20 years ago and mr
whitmore wasn't there in class my
teacher told me he was in a hospital i
jumped on the computer and started
typing a letter to mr wittmeyer i wrote
him to tell him that he what he meant to
me and how he touched my life i gave the
letter to my teacher since she said she
was heading to the hospital to see him i
looked at my teacher and said i don't
care what you do and how you do it but
make sure he gets this letter mr whitmer
passed 10 days later on january 16 2002.
i walked into class and my teacher took
me to the hallway to tell me the bad
news she also had a box and a card in
her hand she handed me this box and card
and mr whitmer wanted me to give you
this mr whitmeier left me his world war
ii backpack wow wow
i cried and cried
was the first time i had lost someone i
loved this backpack represents freedom
patrick represents sacrifice love i want
you to have this gift from me and from
mr whitmire i know i don't know you
patrick but i'm so damn proud of you and
thankful for this it's freaking
emotional right let me tell you guys
this is the value of a person making a
positive impact in a 13 year old kid
that is now 35 years old american
cuban first generation his parents set
an example this you know what this
represents to me values and principles
that's right this is values and
principles this is what we all want when
we were kissed this is what a 16 year
old kid that maybe doesn't have it in
his [ __ ] he just wants somebody to
say listen lead
this is tough make the tougher choice
don't make the easier choice we are
living in a generation that these types
of mystery no one's going to know mr
whitmeier
he's not going to be a guy that's going
to be known story's going to be written
about this guy but he made an impact in
a 13 year kid's life gives him this 20
years later
scott rodriguez gives it to me so i know
this whole thing kind of i don't know
how this happened but we're going there
and you make the comment about
redemption and then we see the gallup
article that we saw yesterday on drudge
that we're talking about it that goes to
scott rodriguez scott i don't know if
you're watching this or not if you are
i appreciate you for this give your gift
you're an absolute stud uh
more power to you for the parents that
raised you and as well as you being able
to give love to teacher like him and in
sharing this sentiment with me this is
gonna be in our podcast set i thank you
for this kind gift anyways we need more
stories like this amazing you have a mr
whitmeier story you have a mr whitmeier
story you have a mr whitmeier story we
all have a mr whitmeier story right so
if you're watching this you know maybe
maybe let's give a little bit credit and
stories to people like that in our lives
you got an instagram profile with 800
followers make a video and share the
story of your mr whitmeier okay i
remember years ago
i was at glendale high school 1.8 gpa
14 years old health and guidance teacher
this lady named sinclair was tough on me
challenged me i would always sit in the
back i never sat in the front i'm not a
front-sitting type of guy i sit in the
back because that's the you know you can
get away with a lot of stuff
she's like hey patrick you're sitting
right here she sits me right in front of
her which i'm like this is the worst
real estate i don't want to sit here
because accountability is high the front
accountability is low in the back
so next thing you know
listen by the way she's 4 11 on a good
day okay
and long story short she's a major in
the army
because of her i later on joined the
army
i went back at 28 years old and i
surprised right now at 33 years old 34
years old there's the videos online i
surprised her we took her a bunch of
gifts i talked to the principal she had
no clue i was doing this in front of all
her students i said how she changed my
life and do you know miss sinclair and i
for the last 12 years we've been pen
pals
she writes me letters when she dates a
guy she says i want you to meet this guy
i go have lunch with the guy and i say
what do you think she calls me
afterwards we've done this multiple
times this woman changed my life she's a
regular human being that
made an impact on a 14 year old kid's
life that are 43 years old 30 years
later we remember that we need to tell
those stories
those day-to-day people that made a
positive impact we can't forget them we
got to recognize those folks as well
because if we don't the market's not
going to do it so anyways that was my
rant scott you the man apparently you're
on i'm glad you saw this and uh you're
getting a shout out appreciate you for
the gift that backpack story was dude
i thought it was like a vintage cool
thing to you the story now this thing is
by the way this look at this man people
going to walk past can you zoom in on
this is there a way to zoom in on the
the the what do you call it on his uh
plot carl ray whitmer
uh u.s navy world war ii was born august
20th 1924 died january 16 2002
loving husband father and grandpa and
obviously a leader as well
uh shout out to this man for what he did
to impact a 13 year old kid's life and
now on pbd podcast
what a freaking story i love that story
and i love stories like that and i think
that it's easy
to talk about big names like we always
talk about the politicians and the names
of influencers and all of this stuff and
we say you know kim kardashian has a
ripple effect or throughout the nation
when she says something beyond meat
whatever ridiculous thing she's saying
these days but you know
really when we talk about morals and
character
it's these people you know when you talk
about a kid who feels motivated he grows
up poor and he feels motivated to build
something you know it's going to be that
teacher that guidance counselor that
camp counselor that pulled him aside and
told him a story and said you can be
anything you want to be it's not always
the parents by the way people always say
parents parents it's not always parents
not everyone has the privilege of being
in a family where parents are supportive
sometimes it's people on the outside
like the camp counselor like the teacher
but
that's why i always go back to like the
breakdown of community is the problem
the breakdown of all church i don't care
you're religious you're not religious
church is a place where people go and
they form a community it's people who
care about each other it's people who
make that eye contact handshake families
get to know each other
it's that is what shapes these young
kids into turns you know boys into men
girls into women
turns turns you into someone that's not
gonna hide behind you know some stupid
emoji or whatever it is on your phone
and say something nasty to somebody on
social media but instead it's gonna look
somebody in the eye and have a real
conversation so these are the stories
that build people and these are the
people that need to be highlighted you
know i wish people you're right people
who have a small number of followers on
their accounts instead of talking some
nonsense about kim k or whoever whoever
the the person of the moment is
highlights stories like this that remind
everyone of the importance of these
communities this story shook me today
i'm so glad you showed up awesome
yeah just like during during uh the
pandemic who's the guy from the office
that just did the good news and it was
you know positive you don't know you
guys know what i'm talking about who's
the guy from the office during the
pandemic he shot something that was just
called the good news which character
from the office um the one that was like
he was like flirting with the the office
assistant the whole time what's it
called good news uh it was the guy from
the office what's his name i don't know
anyway he was just doing this it was
just stuff like this and positive
stories i think they i think he sold it
to like a network because that's the
people oh yeah that guy right there john
krasinski
he did something yeah he did a military
talk about jim yeah yeah it was just
positive and loving stories and all all
positive stuff which we don't get to
hear and nobody gives a damn about but
dude that some good news
and i think i wish i wish the local news
i i'd very rarely watch local news but
when you do watch it it's very
depressing so-and-so was murdered today
yeah so-and-so
it's just story after story and i get it
like these are stuff
and they sensationalize horrible things
but like uh
on uh
i never watched it but i remember there
was a robin mean she does she's the girl
that she's like the face of cnn
headliner not cnn
yeah she always does like the the you
know morning sunshine like the good
story of the day like heartwarming
stories
need more of those yeah you need more
more mr whitman it needs to be
highlighted the thing is this stuff is
happening it's just not a money maker
exactly it's not a headline grabber
that's it's not going to make people mad
and fired up and then you know
sometimes it's not about being mad and
yeah it's about being grateful you know
you know you know what the challenge is
i think here's what the challenge is
so we know what what weekend this is
it's the weekend that gets skipped it's
father's day weekend right father's day
doesn't get it gets 1 100 of the
recognition that mother's day does for
many reasons but it's father's day right
so
what what's what's what's the one thing
we like we want recognition now
we want results now
we want to be told that the little
conversation we have with our son we see
the you know residual effects of it when
now we want to go to the gym and see the
six-pack now we want to go out there and
read a marriage book and our marriage
gets fixed now we want to go buy a
mutual fund or a stock or bitcoin and we
want to become rich now right everything
is now
but but sometimes you have to know that
that little value you taught to your son
or your daughter you're probably not
going to see the positive effects of it
for 30 40 years and you have to be okay
with that sometimes when you go buy that
mutual fund or the stock and you're
trying to be a millionaire tomorrow
you're probably not going to see the
results of it for 10 or 20 years it's
okay be patient sometimes when you go
start a podcast and you're by yourself
nobody is there and you hear 20 people
like i remember we would do something
like 13 people oh [ __ ] we got 13 people
i wonder who these 13 people are
definitely not my relatives definitely
not to be
okay to all the 13 people out there
thank you for listening right and then
you realize later on 2 3 5 10 20 years
later there is impact right
so we have to
understand and be a long-term thinking
to know that the positive impact
a person is making a great teacher i say
great teacher because there's there's
the ones that go above and beyond great
leaders great parents great mothers
great fathers those that take this stuff
seriously
you're rarely going to be rewarded for
the great job you're doing today you're
not going to get rewarded for a decade
or two and that's okay
because when
the recognition is given the impact is a
thousand times more than you would have
gotten instantly so just be patient
don't expect to do good i've had a guy
that was working with me
years ago i really believed in this guy
a lot
uh but he was overly uh negative overly
arrogant
and everybody had a hard time working
with this guy this was a sales office i
was running like in 2004 2005 insurance
i was sitting down i'm like listen man
listen do you realize
you've had so many jobs the last 10
years
and you sit in front of me and when it's
just you and i all you talk about is how
all your bosses were bad okay
you have to understand maybe one boss
i'll buy maybe two boss i'll buy but if
you tell me eight bosses were bad i have
a problem with that and you have to be
aware of this that it's not the world
you're extremely capable you're
extremely talented
you have a heart inside somebody in your
family ruined you a little bit what
words they said or they made your life
easier your damn your mommy babied you
and you're just a little pansy now a
little bit someone needs to tell you
but if you can depensify yourself
and toughen up a little bit i think one
day you can truly make a massive impact
in your life this is a late night
conversation that we had he'll remember
this
so what happens six months later he
leaves okay and now i'm the enemy i'm
the new boss
guy so now so he's trashing me behind
closed doors and you know this
i'm like dude i'm so patient i said dude
i'm gonna get that phone call
what happens five years later i get that
phone call he's the president of a bank
a hundred employees
report to him and work with him he's
making killer money he calls me he says
you have no idea how hard it is to make
this call and how much i've been looking
forward to making this call i said tell
me why
i said you know of course i know who you
are i've spent a lot of time we ran a
lot of appointments together he says do
you know what i'm doing right now i have
no clue he says i'm officially the
president of such and such bank he sends
me the details i don't want to disclose
it he's making multi-six figures he's
killing i got a wife got kids
he says pat no one in my life talked to
me the way you talked to me that day my
own family wouldn't challenge me the way
you challenged me but i've been re
living that conversation the last five
years and i finally realized it is on me
it was my fault it wasn't my boss's
fault and i took responsibility look at
my life now those are my favorite phone
calls and by the way i am so patient
because i received those calls all the
time maybe not in a year maybe not two
maybe not three maybe not five maybe not
ten but you're going to get that calls
because eventually we realize
the only way you can change your life is
what
through you the only way things change
is through taking personal
responsibility that's the only way
things change so you know
to those that sometimes we are so
conditioned social media to point you
mate we want the likes now we want the
shares now we want the views now
yeah relax yeah future looks bright you
know who has a lot of conversations like
that dads
dads
dads my dad sits me down you know you
brought up father's day i just want to
say like shout out to all the dads
dads are so important big time i mean in
my house my dad i would sit down with my
dad my husband always jokes with me and
he says i love you because you have so
much self-respect and you know my dating
history we'll probably get into this at
some point on your show but my dating
history was like i don't put all the
goods out there you know i'm not like
that i'm very selective those
conversations the reason i'm the way
that i am came from conversations i had
with my dad powerful my dad taught me
like you need to respect yourself or
they won't this is how you need to be
treated by a man this is how a man
treats you this is how a boy treats you
know the difference those conversations
happen with my dad conversations about
discipline and school everyone who
everyone here knows you probably already
figured out i have no patience it's not
a good trait
my dad is always on the phone like be
patient it's a virtue you must learn
patience i'm working at it but those
those important conversations yes i'm
close with my mom you know we're like a
girls club my mom and i she's my best
friend
but don't underestimate the power of a
dad and it just reminded me i know
you're a dad i know you love your kids
so much but that what you just did is
something that dads do so well and it's
so important to have those kinds of
conversations to be straight with your
kids shout out to the dads it just
reminded me of my dad and how he talks
to me sometimes you need that reality
again yeah and my dad does it in a very
different way for my mom my mom and i
can kind of be like did you see yes i
did and she agrees with me and we're
like but my dad sometimes is like hold
up you know this is and and he really
made me into someone people say when
people say to me you're a badass i'm
like thanks dad every time every time so
shout out to dad's tony tony he's
listening
you know how they say anyone can be a
dad but not everyone can be a father
yeah
father figures is is super important or
a father lee figure is so important and
by the way you know i gave jedediah like
a slow clap earlier i want to give you a
clip i don't know like
you're going to be clapping i'm going to
clap in mode
yeah good move
but what you said is is so freaking
powerful pat because it kind of goes
back to my point where we're arguing
it's like look you can go every excuse
no oh the president of the politics it's
like you got to look in the mirror and
you got to take some accountability for
yourself and that's really what the what
i don't know the that's sort of the
message listen i mean it's so weird how
this whole thing came about and it was
this was not part of a podcast not at
all this is all because of scott
rodriguez it's your fault scott and we
appreciate you for doing this yes
scott's a millionaire happy father's day
thank you everybody happy father's day
to the guy that created all this
gabriel
he's my guy he's a fan of yours
he used to be a fan of mine but now
since i started talking more risque
stuff he's moved up by the way happy
father i love you tyler as well oh yeah
yes happy father's day okay so let's go
let's go to the next story let's go to
the next story let's take the story of
amazon i want to know what uh
what our friend here vinnie has to say
so amazon says it's going to start
making prime deliveries by drone later
this year in
california okay is that a good idea or a
bad idea another insider story so amazon
packages you receive later this year
could be delivered by a drone not a
driver at least if you live in lochland
lockerford lockford california customers
there will be
seen items available for prime air
delivery on amazon they'll make purchase
as usual and a drone will fly to the
designated delivery location the device
will descend into the customer's
backyard hover hover and release the
package and fly back again amazon says
this drones have a sense
and avoid system that helps them spot
both stationary and moving objects to
avoid colliding with people pets other
aircrafts other obstacles
the drones course correct if they
identify obstacles in order to avoid
them and when descending at a customer's
home they make sure the surrounding area
is empty for landing do you believe i
don't trust any of that [ __ ]
first of all like think about eli it's
not like elon musk is behind this
technology and even his cars have been
crashing and doing whatever but brooke
like can you just imagine the excuses
for like
where's my package i can't like listen
out of our control a hawk attacked the
[ __ ] out of your thing it fell on them
just think about it i think about it
malfunctioning and falling on people
like and how big how big of a package
are they saying that they're going to be
sending i mean what how big is it did
they specify they didn't say microwave
no you know just baseballs like what are
they what are they said they brought i
don't trust it i mean
if we're 10 12 years old and you got a
bb gun you're a kid dude that's like
target practice
imagine the problems are going to come
what are you going to maneuver like a bb
gun
like this like legit drone yeah what do
you think i don't think it's going to be
insane
like there's enough stuff in the sky
like with airplanes and stuff it's like
you're now you're gonna have drones
flying around it's scary bro i trust uh
i trust jeff bezos
i think he's gonna figure it out
you're the only one tyler pull up this
website
it's
relentless.com that's his website no no
this is relentless.com what do you
think's going to come up
relentless.com
boom goes to amazon this guy
ain't
stopping he's figured it out he'll
continue to figure it out
look elon musk gets all the headlines
he's dating the you know the women he's
doing all the right you know but loki
jeff bezos
is that you adam i'm just saying no i'm
definitely not the
the loudmouth guy you know vinnie no you
know what it's like bro but i think this
guy's gonna figure it out i think he's
got a long term vision if i get hit in
the head with a fallen package from
amazon i'm suing the show
let me ask you this how much of this do
you think about if you're listening i'm
curious i want to hear your commentary
how much of this do you think it's
us
uh not wanting to embrace change
and how much of it is just weird period
no it's weird listen let me just
announce this now keep the drones off my
lawn
all like did i ever tell you the story
in brooklyn when jeremy was butt naked
walking through the apartment in the
drone no oh yeah jeremy's at home like i
saw the photos
my mother said that to him he was like
my mother hadn't exchanged with him once
and she was like oh i heard about the
drone and he's like did you see it on
the internet he was so paranoid his
pictures his nude pictures were going to
be on the internet but yeah they were
surveilling my building and they just
didn't tell us they were doing something
and it just rose up and jeremy was butt
naked i was like no i'm out on dru all
this stuff i'm out on ai interesting i'm
out i'm out i don't need it i will what
is it so hard to go get your packages at
the front i mean you know what i'm
saying why do you have to modernize
everything why does everything need to
look like this all those drivers are
going to be you know there's going to be
less drivers
it all comes down to this are you a
flintstones girl or are you a jetsons
girl you guys know the flintstones i
don't need to fly i don't need to get
you all know i would hop into delorean
tyler knows and go back to 1985 if i
could but no there's some things that
just don't need to be modern this will
be abused my answer to you is that this
sounds all cool right now sounds great
sounds fun reality glasses you put them
on you're like oh there i am in an
alternate universe give it a minute it
will be abused there will be
surveillance
this thing will be on when it's not
supposed to be on they're watching us
it's gonna happen tyler delorean this is
just the new delorean do you have lori
and patrick i do not listen if i had the
cash
i would get a delorean
back to the future style i'm going to be
so jealous they're selling this these
are real cars now i'll tell you this if
you can get a delorean back to the
future style i will honestly i don't
even know if i'll be able to continue to
work here
you like it that much no joke oh my god
and if you can figure out how to take
people back and forth in time that's
another level you'd want the flex
capacitor you want that thing right here
i want it all
twenty 1.21 gigawatts he wants all this
that's a great topic too tyler we should
do this make a note would you go back in
time or would you go forward in time
because those are that separates two
different types of people in the
population what would you do would you
rather go back to the future or go to
the future
go back like in history or go to the
future i'd go back and grab the small
sports almanac that's what you got you
and that's right
you and emmett now he's making the money
now i'm making a point you and biff to
be honest i think i would go back to see
great moments like amazing moments of
history that happened and like you know
i mean like that that mold very good
question by the way would you we'll give
a year would you rather go back or go to
the future right there let's put that
poll out twitter i kind of go i i
personally don't pull out there just to
witness amazing moments what did you see
where things were
because the future's
whatever it's just going to be like she
said like all the meta and all that
stuff what are they trying to say how
about this pick a year you want to go to
you go first vinnie we'll go around
people here like a year
and write it in the chat by the way
would you want to go back to the you
know in the past back to the future look
at me giving up my channel next to the
pb or do you want to go to the future
and see what it looks like and give the
year that you want to go to i think this
is a great time
it's amazing
go ahead don't take too long just pick
it here
1978 when i was born there you go that's
what i would i would love to see what
was going on and who was around the
people and people that were just like
there's another kid or somebody that was
like i love him he's cute i like 1992.
i like 1992 there was just enough of
modernization i love the 90s
tyler tyler knows bill clinton i love
the president listen i don't know fresh
prince is the coolest time
clinton but you know there was good
comedy yeah there was fun life was fun
it was before all these phones you had a
good time 90s were good people who were
hanging out in the 90s i would pick a
different high school my high school
experience sucked i'd go different i'd
want to go back like as an adult though
i want to enjoy it as i am now you know
90s 90s girl all the way
i'm going back to 1776. i want to see
what's going down on patreon i want to
see what's going i want to be in that
room i want to see ben franklin but with
all the money you have now right yeah
of course hamilton i want to see george
w
i just want to see those conversations
the founding fathers of this country
what we are today those conversations
being in the room what would you look
like with that gear on if you actually
have cameras
i have a knee oh my god pictures
please pull up okay you can find it
right now
pull up uh valuetainment money ben
franklin please tell me this dropped out
tim please tell me this pops up the
thumbnail as adam you come on as a guest
on my show i'm gonna need you to be in
that entire episode please please tell
me
those are your two options oh they don't
have it i don't have it
they put me my face on bench i look
disgusting it was not a good look it
didn't work by the way if i said that i
could one one figure in american history
who i could go um
kick it with ben franklin really dude
that guy did everything he you know he
was like 40 years older than all those
guys than george washington like james
madison
he was the og he was inventing things he
was also a ladies man he was he's a big
fan he was like adam let's go hang out
you're like we're gonna do with some
girls he's like no i'm going to fly this
kite with some metal on yeah exactly i'm
going to start some [ __ ] pat what about
you yeah
i'm really trying to think i mean it
would be to meet certain characters i
already know your answer brother so i
wouldn't mind i mean you're going to
you're going to think shaw like i'd want
to go to a certain era with the shah
yeah i would want to know alexander what
it was like when when he was doing what
he was alexander the great oh yeah oh
you're going back thousands i'd be so
curious you know what he was doing i'd
be curious to know what it was like like
to be where you know jesus is walking
just curious to know what it was like
you know what kind of criticism
was it during that season i'd love to go
to 1776 where you're going
uh yeah it would be it would be that
because if you go to the future let's
just say you go 100 years from now like
2122. how crazy is it oh my god is it
filled with drones like what is it what
is considered sexy are people working
what do houses look like are there cars
is there smartphones are there
smartphones like a thing of the past
like no one's using smartphones anymore
by the way that you look like top gun in
there look at that picture he looks like
he looks like he belongs in town that
picture i'm going to i'm going to read
my way to the danger
look at that face right there
that's your new tinder
i like that wow that's a good i did that
for john stossel
i said i said i respect your mustache
was it johnstown yeah yeah it could have
been john yeah i respect that much
tyler we just had this conversation no
one picked the future because we're all
little fearful we're all a little if not
fearful just like good point i don't
know who knows which tells you are we
going in the right direction here no
there's too much going on that we don't
like that we're uncomfortable with that
we're unsure about yeah but i feel like
you for one would have plunged in we're
getting older yes
or maybe we're getting older that's the
thing i read a time magazine uh
where the cover said how
you know the next generation they're
such a narcissist all they want to do is
take pictures of themselves and all this
stuff and i'm reading i'm like wow
right all right and then the writer ends
the article in the best way
so if you agreed with everything i said
maybe you're right or maybe you're just
getting old and then the article just
drops out
by the way
let's give a shout out to brian callan
cause he told the story the last time he
was there on the podcast a few weeks ago
where you were on vinnie yeah and he and
he wrote this letter but uh the kids
don't get it these days they're so
entitled that you know they they you
know they take things for granted
they're you know they're like kids kids
kids kids kids signed
socrates
yeah wasn't it was it plato or soccer
whoever it was and it's just like as you
get older young you don't these young
kids don't get it you know what we
should do we should hit like a man on
the street and ask people of all ages
around florida what i'm curious if it is
an age thing i love that hit it out and
be like hey if you could go would you go
forward would you go backward what year
would you pick why actually i'm curious
if it's a generational divide
i like it let's do it i think either
vinnie or adam or any other guys here
with the natal natalia would you i think
the younger people would definitely go
to the future obviously but the older
people what if they know that can you
how amazing if they say no then we're
like we're all fun
we're all [ __ ]
yeah that's i mean that's hilarious
like a 16 year old like
i think it's um you know that we talk
about the fear and greed index the back
going backwards is nostalgic
right going forward is uncertainty so
you know what you're getting yourself in
the past and you know
you're only going to highlight the good
right so in the future you don't know
what the hell is going to happen do we
have houses yeah i think we're going to
have houses and smartphones but we might
not have a phone in your hand you might
you think we're wearing clothes
you think they're still closed yeah yeah
i think they're still close you think
we're still covering ourselves up you
think people care about that you think
it's so crazy you i mean you think like
i'm not joking because you think like at
that point so many people
have campaigned about you know walking
around new that many people are not
wearing clothes and we've accepted it
yeah i know it sounds like a weird by
the way i know you say it's weird dude
look some of these that were accepted
today in america shit's crazy 30 years
ago you would have said no way in the
freaking world you think 40 years from
now you're like going to the mall
50 of walking people just naked and
you're not even looking at them just
like that's just another another naked
we're so like
immunization i don't like that at all i
don't like that look at all i don't know
i think
people are gross depending on where you
go south beach
by the way from a party boys to party
man to party grandpa yeah that's adam
i'm calling guilt so look i think i
think it's a perfect time to bring up a
story that uh a love story it's a very
very it's a special moment here
amber hurt admits she still loves johnny
depp oh man isn't that like it takes me
back to like notebook right
amber hurt has admitted that she
absolutely still loves her ex-husband
johnny depp yes absolutely absolutely i
love him i love him with all my heart
and i tried the best
i could
to make a deeply broken relationship
work and i couldn't i have no bad
feelings or will towards him at all i
know that might be hard to understand or
it might be really easy to understand if
you ever loved anyone however despite
the actress admitting that she still
loves her former spouse she once
again doubled down on her allegations
that he physically abused her throughout
the relationship hitting back at the
claims that she faked bruising uh in
order to incriminate him insisting that
she would have been accused of lying
whether or not she had visible injuries
so
what do you think about some of the
comments i feel like she's got to get
away and just be quiet and she's just
making it worse for herself right she's
hoping she's going to be nice with stuff
like this where he's like all right you
don't have to pay me the what it's eight
million or whatever she owes them oh
he's not he's not a dummy like let me
she's going to take 100 let me tell you
dude let me give you basic math how many
years did she steal from him
um six years six months okay
takes six years
when you're when you're 50 years old and
you got 30 more years to live
what's 6 divided by 30
20 yes she took 20 of your life that's a
lot of life
okay you think he's going to give that
up for a creative guy like him that his
highest of creating movies and playing
characters that's his escape that's his
art
that's 20 of your life that was stolen
from you so you think that's that's her
pitch though she's like hey i'm i love
and i love you and there's love i don't
know if it was stolen pat he's a big boy
he can make his own decisions at any
point he could have been like get out
but he stayed in it i don't get it yeah
that's a good question why did he stand
like get out bro anybody's in a toxic
relationship go have a conversation with
leonardo dicaprio and he shows you how
you should act no
he's a bad boy listen
so at this
have you seen how this guy looks he's
like one chromosome away from being a
girl this guy's a extreme johnny he's
part of the brad pitt community they're
just they're too they're too pretty
right what a terrible yeah not these
days though he's a little fat bloated
but but here's here's what you got to
say when you're in it
and you left a great marriage and you go
into it with somebody like her
and your own daughters maybe didn't want
this situation
it's a tough place to be it's a very
tough place to be that he went through
but anyways do you believe
like do you believe amber's doing this
to what to kind of get the media to be
nicer to her do you believe it's a
message to him or she just playing games
again i think she was so humiliated i
mean it was so obvious to everyone i
don't know one person left right center
no matter how you feel about me too
movement believe all women any of that i
don't know one person that watched her
testimony or any of it and believed what
she was saying i mean it was deeply
embarrassing what she did her name is a
full-on joke at this point she did it
herself
and she she did a lot to discredit the
movement
and she
she brought this on herself so i think
she's embarrassed humiliated
she knows full well that everybody with
with a brain with any sense of reality
walked away from that and said she lied
she made this up what a disgrace
i think people who do really believe in
the movement me too movement and believe
all women i don't i don't think you
should believe all women on moment one i
think you have to investigate these
things and everyone's entitled to get up
a proper investigation but
i think she's humiliated and it's like
what do i what do you say at this point
what do you say now this is idiocy
because everyone's gonna be like this is
your line you destroyed him publicly you
brought this up you lied you made it
into this big thing you're now
humiliated now you're going to say you
love the guy come on no one's buying
this no one's going to be like oh she
loves him no not one person what happens
to her like you know oj
what he did
he comes back
oh jay oh yeah yeah yeah
comes back oh jay and he does what he
does it took a while though took a while
and by the way he's not he he's not
somebody that is accepted like sasha
baron cohen did an interview with him if
you've not seen it you have to watch it
it's uncomfortable i'll show it to you
afterwards it's ridiculous yeah
on what he did it's it's seriously like
what the way he called them out was very
guy and weird brings this drop that
gorgeous italian model in
and he's he's talking to her in italian
but it's [ __ ] he doesn't speak
italian yeah of course and he says this
is oj oj oj buffalo billah you know
he's like
so anyway so even oj making a comeback
sasha you know
what happens to amber hurt oh i think
she can make a comeback you think she
can make a comeback listen everything's
possible hollywood is a different world
yeah they'll cast her dale
not right away though i think she's
going to have to sit it out for a minute
um i think there are people legitimately
women in hollywood who aren't mad about
this because they feel like she did
discredit what they were trying to do
but they're also going to be people that
give it a minute and they'll rally
they'll be like oh this was a ploy
she was taken advantage of they'll go
with some stupid talking point no one
else believes hollywood will resurrect
one of her
redemption they americans love that yeah
she look look at her all the unbattled
stuff and now she's dude she'll be in a
movie in a year or two guaranteed think
about 200
think about the metaphor we're making
right now
what
a legend murderer killing his ex-wife
and the other guy shout out to cato
caleb and tom zenner by the way um
murderer yep
fake domestic abuse
not exactly apples to that let me ask
you who would you put on
you look at what happened mel gibson he
was a top five best actor at the time
when he was speaking to alex disappeared
right and my one of my favorite actors
to watch the guy was hilarious and he
was a great actor you know so he's a
good looking guy
very very good looking guy yeah but but
who's going to make a comeback first her
or kevin spacey
her it's going to be her because she's
still young relatively hot it depends on
the topic at hand and the appetite like
how upset are people about it what's the
mood of the moment on that topic you
know if it's something racist or forget
it i mean it's it's done but if it's
something like this i think she's got a
little bit more leeway and again adam
you're right you can't compare you know
the oj story but if we're talking about
media and hollywood that's the
conversation you know it's not about the
severity of what was done it's about the
media's appetite to resurrect scott just
gave good perspective scott h so who
make a comeback first her or jessie
smollett
let me pronounce it correctly
very good point juicy uh jesse smith
he he got released out of pr he's still
out of prison you know right they
released him because of his mental
pressure panicking
but he was arrested he was like you know
if i i'm not going to commit suicide he
did all that spiel yeah and then two
days later they they got him out i don't
know what shhh
spiel
use the little schmidt
that's beautiful so who
you know why though i think because
there are too many people in positions
of power who agreed with him who propped
him up they're not going to want to
admit they you know they don't they
don't want their reputations ruined so
they're going to have to everyone's
going to have to forget about this real
fast that they can have their
reputations you know reinstated
interesting well that's not that's what
i forget who amber heard went after
either it wasn't some joe schmoe nobody
it was johnny
johnny depp is exceptionally beloved by
the people yeah i don't think she can
recover from this 4.6 million people
have signed this petition to remove her
from aquaman too wow
that's a lot johnny depp is done with
disney now think about all the
phenomenal like just for disney movies
people loved him as captain jack sparrow
charlie and the chocolate factory et
cetera et cetera et cetera and pat you
know what you know and going off of
tyler you know i love johnny depp he
would dress up as jack like the entire
everything from head to toe and go to
like cancer hospitals and these kids
were like oh my dude you want to talk
about crying watch one of those videos
and tell me if you could not cry
throughout the whole thing it's amazing
he's he's an amazing guy just you know
really shitty and he really like if you
watched some of the testimony in the
trial he just kept it together he did he
was just cool calm and collected and she
came off crazy by the way some people
may call that acting
whoa well then world tour
she sucks and she shouldn't be in movies
anyway because she sucks as if she was
trying to pull that off
sorry
many people in hollywood are uh suck but
they're extremely attractive and that
helps so you can be a five as an actor
but ten as a
looks and you can have a place in
hollywood and work your way up so don't
forget we're in the attention economy
and she gets eyeballs i don't think
jesse smollette gets eyeballs like she
does think of all the people news people
i mean
the power that defended him let me ask
you would we want to interview her here
110
okay can we reach out let's make a note
we'll reach out and you know we'll even
you know support a charity of her
choosing yeah didn't she want to give
some money to uh what do you call it to
uh uh what would those two charities you
want
yeah we'll support we'll help a
proportion pledged six million dollars
what will help with a portion of that
place
in the green room
we'll be fine
no pooping no problem yeah no problem
exactly all right let's go to the next
one so bitcoin bitcoin we talked about a
little bit but uh there's a few things
that's going on with bitcoin and it's
like three stories in one
uh one of them is what happened with
bitcoin it goes to twenty thousand two
hundred okay we know that already on how
big of a drop it is nearly sixty six
percent
drop off it's an 18 month low of where
bitcoin is at
uh el salvador is down 52 million
dollars on the bitcoin that they bought
having invested more than 104 million
dollars purchasing bitcoin for the
national treasury in the 10 months since
buying it it's legal tender el
salvador's holdings are now valued at
51.5 million dollars more than 50 lost
bitcoins price at press time was 22 400
the president has announced 10 purchases
of bitcoin since uh september of 2021
the country at last
checked
301 bitcoins acquired at an average of
45 000
by the way if you believe in dollar cost
averaging maybe not a bad time to buy
some more bitcoin and coinbase lays off
18 their workforce
as executives prepare for recession and
crypto winter wow coinbase is laying off
almost a fifth of their workforce amid a
collapse in the stock market in crypto
prices coinbase has roughly 5000
full-time employees transitioning
translating to a head count
reduction of around 1100 people ceo
brian armstrong pointed to a possible
recession and need to manage coinbase
burn rate and increase efficiency he
also said the company grew too quickly
uh during the bull market coinbase has
initially uh said it was pausing hiring
two weeks later the crypto giant
announced that it was extending the
freeze
for the foreseeable future earlier
district coinbase said it planned to add
2 000 jobs so think about it
earlier this year in january they said
they're going to add 2 000 jobs in
product engineering and design five
months later not only did they freeze
that but they're letting go of 1800
people how quickly things can change in
just five months adam you have friends
in the crypto community when you're
talking to your peers these are guys
that have names that are known within
that business
what are they saying how low they think
bitcoin is going to go to
um
17 000 was the number i heard from our
good friend leia halpern who you met
she's like obsessed with bitcoin
um she's on fox news all the time that's
sort of her target but they they have a
saying in the bitcoin community they
call it hodl you familiar with this hodl
you know so i i think someone fell
asleep and
was trying to say hold like buy and hold
strategy that's great and they wrote
hotels so in the bitcoin community you
talk about hotels so whether you got it
at 5k or 10k or 20k or 60k you hotel
like it's not it's not any different
from anyone who invests in the stock
market they say have a long-term
strategy don't be a day trader be a
decade trader right buy and hold
strategy and that's how you typically
would win so if you're a hodler or a
hodler you're going to be okay because
you believe
in bitcoin but if you're a day trader
you're trying to get rich quick
you know you might fly too close to the
sun like icarus and get burned we've had
a common theme on this uh on this
podcast today and it's
uh personal accountability and patience
that's been a big thing and if you're
willing to be patient
i'm sure you'll end up fine if you're
freaking out you're going to sell and
you know you know who's actually looking
better than ever these days no shocker
here peter warren buffett oh quittership
peter said because of gold yeah he was
talking a bunch of trash would you say
would you say to start buying like if
you have if you have the money bitcoin
is on sale right now exactly some of the
conversations we've had is i think when
bitcoin hit like 50 or 60k we're like is
it more likely to go to 100k or zero do
you want to reassess that now because i
don't think that bitcoin's going to zero
i think bitcoin's here to stay but
everyone got again so caught up with
just get bitcoin you're gonna rich get
bitcoin you're gonna get rich well i
know a lot of people who bought it 60
and they're you know what 80 underwater
at this point
so if you're a hodler
and you believe in bitcoin long term
things will be okay
my take away from this podcast today is
i need a financial advisor
what's going on here is way over my head
but you know people say i hear people
say all the time oh this bitcoin stuff
this crypto stuff this is for the rich
this is for people who don't you can
just throw a hundred grand here and you
don't worry about it you don't think
about it you don't care about it
whatever happens happens what do you say
to people who don't have like all that
money to spare they wanna they want to
get involved is it too risky just a
general question i know i sound
ridiculous when i ask these questions
but i'm asking for the average well
there's something called asset
allocation right and i've been saying
just follow what the big boys do follow
what the big boys do they're not putting
100 of their money in freaking bitcoin
they put three percent or five percent
right like you've got some bitcoin some
crypto it's probably one percent of your
net worth give or take right the problem
is when you're so obsessed with bitcoin
and you think it's the only thing out
there and
i all i do is i buy bitcoin and i buy
more bitcoin it's like yeah but how are
you paying brent how are you buying
right what are you saying
so like we we talked you brought up el
salvador right the president yeah naive
right
this country
has been like the biggest advocate for
buying bitcoin for the last x amount of
years right pat like this guy the
country as itself as far as it's like
beloved by the crypto community exactly
he's like the guy you know how much did
they put in exactly so he bought 100
million dollars 100 million and he
bought it 60k okay so at 45k 4045 so
they've all over a 50 loss yeah okay all
right the country's going to crumble i
assume i come here no but let's look at
his asset allocation he said right here
the el salvador finance minister
alejandra zalia said the bitcoin losses
posed extremely
minimal risk of the country's fiscal
position why because he noted that the
amount
puts less than
0.5
of the government budget so they didn't
go all in on bitcoin
one percent i tell people all the time
you know you should if you're young you
should be in probably 80 stocks maybe 10
bonds
obviously you need to have cash and then
dabble in some more riskier investments
listen anybody who's shocked that this
happened to bitcoin has been tuning out
what everyone's been saying bitcoin is a
volatile asset it's a risky investment
don't put all your money in it so you
either tuned out the noise or you went
all in i'll give you some feedback here
my feedback is don't put money in
anything you know nothing about
period
if you want to put money in it go learn
and don't even just lean on your
financial advisor i've been a financial
advisor for 20 plus years i start off
with morgan stanley don't lean on your
financial advisor the relationship i
have with my financial advisors i'm
constantly asking questions i'm asking
like i had a question for them yesterday
with strike they're about to go public
what's going to happen with strat public
you know all these other guys that are
going to go
public what's happened to the public
market what are we looking at with rates
you know crypto all these other things
to learn but for you
like hey pat man you made all this money
cards i'm gonna go buy some cards don't
unless if you know
about sports and players okay
uh uh only put the money and things that
you know about so
so that's one formula so then this means
well what do i want to go learn if you
want to go learn real estate go learn
real estate before you invest into real
estate if you want to go on crypto go
learn before you invest if it's stocks
equities go learn before you invest
almost every stock right now is on sale
and no one's going to get it right of
what the bottom's going to be nobody
ever gets it right and those who do they
got lucky because the only way to judge
that you fully fully got it right and
you bought at the bottom as if you can
do it three times no one does it at the
all the way at the bottom okay when the
stock market dropped to 6 500 points you
know in 2008 2009 if you bought it at
whatever the year was 2009 or 2000 if
those who bought it during that time
they got lucky but some people bought at
8 000. some people bought at 10 000. so
there's going to be some luck involved
and many are saying the market's going
to be going even further down i think
this is just getting warmed up i'm
telling you i had a guy yesterday that i
was consulting but runs a mortgage
company does very well
on any given month he was making 100 to
200 000 net last year every month he
bought way too many exotics he bought
way too many crazy cars and i told him i
said listen how much do you have
of expenses saved he says five months
that's a scary thought that's only five
months by the way very very scary
and i said hey
drop your rolls drop your lambo drop the
ferrari
go drive a nissan sentra
go drive a used tesla 40 grand 50 grand
go drive something very simple right now
okay
don't get crazy buying more watches you
don't need another two hundred thousand
dollar watch or a hundred thousand
dollar watch or a fifty thousand dollar
watch right
like first time i bought ferragamo shoes
for 550 dollars i had 250 000 in a bank
first time i bought a house at a half a
million dollars in a bank i didn't go
buy a house i'm like no i'm gonna say so
be a little bit more you know
patient and going aggressive but just
increase your investments increase your
cash flow and choose
which area you want to go learn it's a
very big risk if you're just going to go
across the board i want to put you know
no learn a little bit more before you
jump in and i say something about that
guy right there
i don't mean this like personally
i hope that something bad happened
because financially you're saying i
don't know physically
i'm not even saying that guy i don't
know
i'm saying that story yeah
you're making millions
and you've got five months of savings in
the bank but you've got 10 exotic cars
that doesn't make sense
okay but i don't know why like
like what do you is an ego thing is it i
want to show off thing is it addictive
some people i don't know what it is it's
not it's not it's called over optimism
it's over optimism that this is going to
last longer and it's not right it's not
what's the book you always talk about
which one only the paranoid circle
paranoid survivor he's not paranoid yeah
but but no like listen there is a lot of
value in being optimistic and positive
but you also have to have perspective to
know that you can be as positive and
optimistic you want that things are
going to recover today and then there's
logic and being able to reason you need
a balance of both be positive be
optimistic but at the same time do
research to have backing of your
optimism okay so so that part is oh i
don't think the rates go i think people
like you know how much how pissed off
realtors are with me right now you know
how many of my friends who are real
estate and mortgages are dmc and what
was that all about pat what was that
market crash video all about why are you
i thought we're friends i'm like it's
not about i thought we're friends guys
you're gonna go through it embrace for
impact stop thinking that just because
you made a ton of money the last seven
years because it's been so easy in real
estate and loans that this is going to
be like this forever it's not so
hopefully you're ready for it so and if
you if you were ready for it you
listened to the message great if you
didn't
time to
downsize a lot of things and to do it
very quickly tighten up everything very
quickly
you're getting a little sloppy out there
very very quickly your guts hanging over
your belt all right now so we are
getting to to the end of the podcast
here uh i i want to see if i want to do
one other story before we wrap let's do
one story this is a crazy story here
soros takeover outrage as miami
anti-communism radio mambi
could be controlled by obama clinton
uh staffers so this this story tyler
this is the one you found right is this
uh
you see the story that we have uh
uh you know what no i want to skip that
story i'm going to go to this other
story i don't want to do that story so
this other story i want to do is a is a
very big story for a guy like me but i
think everybody can pick up something
from this story
la approves
unprecedented plan to take over
chinatown apartment building against
owners wishes this is a coindesk story
okay let me say this one more time lau
approves unprecedented plan to take over
a chinatown apartment building against
the owner's wishes okay l.a city council
voted friday to start the process of
acquiring an apartment building in
chinatown where low-income tenants have
faced large rent increases renters and
tenants advocates praised the vote
saying their years of organizing have
led to a significant step towards
preserving affordable rent in their
building for decades the tenants paid
rents that were capped to reflect their
low income but the 30-year agreement to
keep rents low expired a few years ago
allowing the owner to raise rent to
market rates
tenants in the building say rents have
since increased by as much as 300
percent the city's ultimate goal is to
reinstate the building's affordability
covenant for another 55 years let me
explain to you what just happened here
so this guy made a mistake what's the
mistake the mistake is 30 years ago he
went in bed with the government
and he said look this is great
you guys going to bring all the people
here you're going to pay the rent for me
so section 8 all this up freaking
awesome let's do it he signed 30 years
knowing he's going to be fully decked
out because they have to pay to rent to
him 30 years later this this building
that he owns
is now worth 57 million dollars and you
know what the government's forcing to
buy it for 46 million dollars he's
losing 11 million dollars so now
somebody may say oh
cry me a river that's not the point the
government is forcing him to do
something he does not want to do he's
being cornered and forced by the way if
he decides to increase rent by 300
percent what do tenants have the choice
to do move leave to a different place
okay
and he can go from having 50 100 to
place rented down to what 30 20 he'll
pay the price if he increases the rent
right
in 2007 2008 obamacare was being
introduced it was kind of coming out
2009 whatever the year was was kind of
coming out
and i used to sell health insurance in
the early 2000s
the moment obamacare came out everybody
called and said hey pat oh my gosh let
me tell you man we're blowing it up i'm
just i'm selling affordable camera left
and right i'm just 50 policies 80
policies 60
why are you not getting into obamacare
why are you not getting into this
business it's like selling like hot
cakes people are just coming because
they have to buy i said i just i don't
sell
products that is you know by the
government because there is no
complaints there's nobody i can call to
improve
they don't care about online reputation
they don't care about anything anyone
says about them what's the 1 800
customer service call for the government
it does not exist 100 go [ __ ] you
nothing it doesn't exist so yeah what
this guy learned is it was good for 30
years but the government finally said
listen
this is ours now so if this is happening
in california
and other people get excited about this
oh my gosh imagine this becoming a
business model for the government so if
you're in a situation that's tight in
your real estate and you're thinking
about teaming up with these guys you may
want to think twice this
the reason that i think you wanted to
cover this story because it it it
essentially highlights
what you stand for
you got choice or you got force
and you're all about choice options hey
you don't like it you can move great but
when the government forces you to do
something obviously you're familiar with
this you don't like that so much of
course
yeah they don't improve any i mean it's
very rare when you see the government
get involved and something gets better
the quality gets better the price gets i
mean what happens actually even if the
price gets better like you talk about
insurance everyone said oh the costs are
going to go down and i kept saying what
about the quality of care does nobody
care about that is anybody looking at
the other healthcare systems where your
prices went down and there are lines out
the door and those people are fighting
like hell to get the united states to
come and get their care so every time
the government gets involved i guarantee
you with that building with any building
they get involved you're going to see
quite they're going to see a catastrophe
emerge and you're right who do you
complain to when you have the owner of a
building and you have a problem you pick
up the phone you call you have a contact
you have a person that you can
they're not going to be there for you to
answer questions zero deal there's a no
win in that and it's a big headache yeah
that's the common statement when you
complain to somebody that's owned by
working with the government deal with it
yeah great that's right what do they say
that you get um
you've got three options you can only
pick two quality price or time right
like how long it takes to make something
so you can only pick two all right so
look this was a a
great show i enjoyed it a lot two hours
but like five minutes if you enjoyed it
uh give us a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel and jedediah your next show
is when when is your monday 1 p.m
eastern time we're coming in hot we
always come in coming in we're coming in
live we always come in live monday 1pm
eastern standard time you can find her
on jetta diabila live on youtube let's
put the link below as well in the chat
box in the description however today we
got an announcement
a few years ago
i was sitting there and you know my
whole concept of valuetainment is i
think you can inject value but you got
to entertain people because
the last 20 years everywhere i've ran my
sales team it had to have laughter humor
pranks jokes if you work with me in any
of the offices you know that's part of
our mo we have to do that we're famous
on pranks we're famous on doing jokes
i've been doing this since i was a kid
in a family of a bunch of pranksters
and i saw a few years ago where i'm
sitting there watching snl and i said
snow is only making fun of one size
they're not making fun of all the sides
i think there's an opportunity for snl
so we started talking about it in dallas
and then you know we started teaming up
with we brought adam and we started
working together with adam former
comedian we're talking about all this
stuff saying hey what would this looks
like i brought it up to tom what if we
take this route and the next thing you
know tim 2 point that we came out here
vinnie you reached out on instagram yep
and i and randomly yes randomly and i
saw you and i saw bet david and we're
both assyrian and i was like
how's it going and i'm not i'm not bs
within an hour he's back to me and i'm
like oh [ __ ] my friends and family like
dude patrick but david and i was like
yeah i just we're talking and then i
remember i think glendale were randomly
at going to the mall and he calls me i'm
like in the car i'm like
pat what's up and he's like that's a
majority in our language and he's like
what are you doing and i'm like i'm you
know i'm in that lane he's like no what
are you what are you doing what do you
want and i said something like that he's
like are you willing to to move to
florida and i sort of gotta go yup
and in a matter of months i've
packed my [ __ ] i mean i love california
and then i just came here and i was like
i love it
so so so we're very excited about it
because
you know uh in the assyrian community
vinnie is like god and the the comet
everybody when the name vinnie is loved
and you've done a lot of stuff in the
past with kevin hart you don't you don't
suffer with weigh-ins i was on death
comedy jam definitely comedy jam death
comedy jam think about that yeah and uh
we went the other day and we watched you
perform you know this was where
yeah freaking out anyway so so having
said that we're excited to introduce the
latest talent to the valuetainment team
vinnie hoshanna uh my brother is
officially part of the team we're
excited about this it's a big deal
and we are launching valuetainment
comedy and this is gonna be the
beginning of us by the way if you're a
comedian and you like the valuetainment
brand you like what we're doing reach
out to us uh dms we're extremely
aggressive right now by bringing
comedians to the team but we you know
he's got some shows he's gonna be doing
one of them may be called where's vinnie
now some of them maybe call a lot of
different things but you're gonna see
you're gonna see different uh we got
some exciting stuff
and i'm not warning you guys but it's a
comedy channel i'm gonna be funny i'm
gonna be by myself mind you this is who
i am as a person i like to push the
envelope and i like to be out there the
chappelle show push envelopes and this
stuff like that i want to do the same
thing and just you know can we can we
sit can we see the intro let's
essentially just shows how amazing guys
this i came i'm not i'm not a corporate
guy i've never had an office nine to
five i'm here every day these guys the
quality of love that these people show
you've seen
out of this world the parking spot we
you know we've never done that before
what the hell dude
first person did we ever give you a
parking space i don't have a car i got a
i got a [ __ ] parking spot and guys
i'm telling you right now like i said
you should see this never happened
should we show them the parking spot can
you play those guys let's play this game
you don't want to work for this place my
name is
actor and the newest member of
valuetainment
today i'm going to show you what a day
in my life is like working here let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pulling into the office right now i've
never had my own parking spot but here
at valuetainment they really know how to
treat their employees
there we go
and i get it i could see how some people
would complain about the distance of the
spot to the building but i think that
says you know a lot about this company
and that it's health-conscious
among co-workers
i think of bill's character
[Music]
you gotta see the rest to see it go to
valuetainment comedy put the link below
so people can see that's a four minute
clip there's a surprise
uh in the middle and the end for you so
uh uh again you're gonna see a lot of
different things we're gonna do some
live stuff we're gonna do some new shows
we're to be uh collaborations and uh who
knows you may see the whole office doing
some different skits
they're they're amazing yeah the none of
them was actors but everybody's down at
the beginning it's it's gonna be great
the future looks bright no question
about it so go to valuetainment comedy
subscribe put the link below to see the
rest of it and you will see many other
things coming soon here with vineyoshana
vinnie brother it's great to have you
here awesome love you too bro
he's gonna take out our comedic juices
trust me
you guys are going to see adam and some
you might you might even see a cameo of
of patrick and yeah this is one of my
favorite podcasts this is the team now
by the way this is the
diet in the house by the way by the way
i love i love the format of us doing
interviews and going through different
topics i love that because i'm i'm i'm
more interested in what you have to say
than what i have to say so that's why i
love doing the interview style but i
think we got to get to a point the
schedule doesn't permit you got you know
what i'm you know but we're going to get
to a point that we can do one or two of
these every week or we can just talk
like amongst the group with current
events i think the audience really likes
that and we're gonna do our best to
bring that for you as well there's some
that love the interview format they
don't like this format there's some that
like this format not the interview
format but regardless we're going to uh
diversification
i would love to see you guys a lot that
would be sick just you guys live
podcasts that'd be dope
we would do a live who knows we
something's coming soon okay something's
coming soon stay tuned something's
coming soon anyway let me say this
congrats to jedediah gotcha you did your
first full week this this week you
crushed it three shows congrats to
vinnie thank you i love you both thank
you congrats to
superheroes saving jimbo's life are we
not are we not are you not setting up
something podcast with jedediah fresh
aren't you we're gonna we're gonna get
something
stay tuned folks anyways hey have a
great weekend
happy father's day to all the great
fathers out there bless you guys go
watch at a dive show monday 1 p.m
eastern standard time and go to
valuetainment comedy to check out our
video channel's full clip and we've got
a lot of crazy stuff coming up next week
here with adam as well thank you
everybody have a great weekend bye bye
bye
you